Das ist die 200. Ihr kriegt einfach nur das Schlechteste von allem.
Du hast den Telefon auf Deutsch?
Ich könnte davon nicht ganz so viel essen, ihr vertragt wahrscheinlich auch ein bisschen mehr Schärfe.
Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass man sich daran gewöhnt.
Ja klar, man kann es trainieren.
Das heißt, am Ende der Schokolade sind wir auf jeden Fall gut trainiert?
Naja, du hast halt den Effekt, wenn das Schmerz in Femden sehr stark ist, dann bekommst du halt ein Kreislaufproblem. Ja, weil wahrscheinlich der Körper merkt, so ganz viel Schmerz, da muss irgendwo eine offene Wunde sein, fahren wir mal den Kreislauf runter. Also es gibt Leute, denen dann halt schwarz vor Augen wird, bei richtig ordentlich viel Schärfe. Aber das ist vielleicht auch so ein bisschen der Kick dabei.
Wichtiger Tipp, gerade aus dem Chat jetzt nicht mit den Fingern an die Augen gehen.
So, esse ich jetzt noch so ein volles Stück?
Klar, Roddy.
Ich komm damit jetzt besser klar, als ich dachte. Und ich finde das irgendwie total erfrischend.
Ich weiß nicht, ob die Notaufnahme so gut ist. Also ich hab nicht so gute Erfahrungen mit der Notaufnahme hier in der Nähe. Roddy, also nur, jetzt ist es so ein Mund.
Prenzlauberg?
Nee, Vivantes und Friedrichshain.
Stimmt, von dem hab ich auch schlecht erfahren gemacht.
Was macht denn die Notaufnahme die ganze Zeit?
Ich hatte Rücken.
Du hattest Rücken? Ach du liebes Lieschen.
Kommen wir zu den anderen Hörer-Einsendungen. Herrlich, geil. Also Philipp, vielen Dank. Das war jetzt echt ein erotisches Erlebnis.
Hilfe. Und aus letzter scharfer Ding ich will auch. Okay, das war ja immer dein Skype-Held.
Na da ist noch so ein kleiner einzelner Zwiebel.
Du kannst ja voll vergessen.
Wieso?
Zu groß.
Davon habe ich jetzt zwei genommen.
Ja, du bist auch super cool.
Ich habe jetzt schon so eine ganze Ecke genommen, so ein ganzes Teilstück.
Wie ein ganzes Teilstück?
Naja, ein Teilstück.
Hast du so eine normale Schokoladeneinheit?
Hast du jetzt gerade gegessen?
Aber es wird nicht mehr schärfer.
Ach, also es ist egal, wie viel man nimmt?
Ab einem bestimmten Punkt ja.
Wenn die Sattigung erreicht ist, ist die Sattigung erreicht.
Ich finde das ja immer so enttäuschend, wenn man zum Asiaten geht in der Wahl.
Ist schon scharf.
Und versucht scharf.
Also es hat schon Potential. Also wenn mal einer Schilikon-Kane macht und ihr seid nicht zu zufrieden, also wenn irgendwo Schilikon-Kane gekocht wird und ihr seid nicht zu zufrieden, einfach mal so ganz unauffällig so ein Stück Schokolade reinfallen lassen, soll man ja eh machen.
Ja vor allem, weißt du, was du da mit Partys basten kannst irgendwie, wenn du irgendwie diese Schokolade einfach irgendwo in so eine Schale reinlegst.
Nein, das kannst du nicht schon machen. Das ist wie mit Drogenkekse anwenden, ohne Bescheid zu sagen, kann man nicht machen. Das ist nicht ethisch, moralisch vertretbar. Sorry.
Ich würde dir Gedanken trotzdem machen, wie charmant.
Der Gedanke der ganzen Stadt, LSD ins Trinkwasser zu tun, ist auch immer wieder charmant, aber es geht halt nicht.
Kann man nicht machen.
Macht auf jeden Fall einen guten Prank.
Wir hatten noch was anderes. Wo ist der andere? Mir brach das Herz, nur ein Paket und dann noch für den anderen Podcast, oder den falschen Podcast. Alles Gute zum Runden, ihr Meister des Nerd Talks. Für euch noch ein Rätsel. Was ist Counter Kalypse? Eine Gegenbewegung zum Trampismus. Zählwahn aus der Innenperspektive. Krise und Untergang des Web 1.0 zu Beginn der 2000er durch den inflationären Einsatz von PHP-Besucherzählern. Viel Spaß, eine gelungene Sendung und intakte Schmatztasten. Wünscht euch Kinnla für eine weitere große Schokipackung. Diesmal allerdings mit fruchtigen Sorten.
Also diese weiße Schokolade, Kokos, Mango, Maracuja ist sehr zu empfehlen.
Ja, da fällt einem die Kinnla runter.
Da würde ich mal ein Stück vom probieren. Das ist allerdings weiße Schokolade, ne? Du bist noch jetzt doch ganz schön am schlaufen, ne?
Ich bin noch auf...
Hast du nicht gesagt, das kann nicht mehr schlimmer werden?
Ja, es ist halt länger schlimm.
Also falls ich es noch nicht gemacht habe, ich wollte mich nochmal bei dem bedanken, der mir so ein iFixit-Reparatursetter irgendwie hat zukommen lassen. Das braucht ja doch ein bisschen mehr.
Das Gute.
Ich glaube, du hast schon mal, aber ja, macht gut.
Nee, aber falls es nicht war, dann jetzt nochmal auf jeden Fall. Und alle anderen Sachen, die immer so kommen, ist immer sehr nett, wenn man ein Postkonto hat.
Ach so, Hörerbedankung. Übrigens nochmal vielen Dank an den Hörer, der mich angesprochen hat in Dänemark im Legoland Billund. Ich weiß leider deinen Namen nicht mehr, aber das war irgendwie auch schon am Ende des Besuches und ich war super durch.
Bist du an der Stimme erkannt worden oder?
Nee, am Tweet. Nein, ich weiß auch nicht. Vielleicht wusste der, wie ich aussehe oder so, aus irgendeiner Live-Sendung, keine Ahnung. Aber er meinte zumindest, dass er den Tweet gesehen hätte und meinte, der muss ja irgendwo sein und dann hat er mich wohl entdeckt. Ich habe das Einhorn dabei gehabt und meine Kinder hatten es mehr oder weniger nach einem Tag schon durch. Jetzt gibt es nur noch den Hals, der Rest lässt. Den Rest habe ich dann abgemacht, weil das Loch, was da drin war, war so groß. Also es geht um ein Aufpusteinhorn. Genau, ich habe mir so eins dann noch mal von Amazon kommen lassen und habe das dann mit als Überraschung für die Kinder mitgenommen. Nee, an die Ostsee. Und habe das da aufgepumpt und die waren, fanden das super, fanden das super und haben dieses Teil irgendwie so bespielt, dass es wie gesagt nach einem Tag dann durch war, mehr oder weniger geplatzt ist. Und dann habe ich alles, was nicht Hals war, abgeschnitten, weil der Hals, den kann man noch aufpusten. Jetzt habe ich da so ein Einhorn-Hals zu Hause.
So, dann haben wir ja noch eine ungewohnte Einsendung erhalten, nämlich T-Shirts. Vielen Dank an Martin, der offenbar in einem T-Shirt-Laden in England arbeitet und uns hört und tatsächlich irgendwie eine ganze Kiste mit Custom Made Freak Show 200 Shirts rein geschickt hat in mannigfaltiger Ausführung, sag ich mal.
Nee, aber so eine Schätzung, das ist so, ja ich würde sagen, 40 könnten es auch sein.
Mehr als Eigenbedarf und ich denke, wir werden das mal nutzen, um hier den Leuten, die hier jenseits der direkten Mikrofonansprache diesen Podcast auf die eine oder andere Art und Weise mitgetragen haben, hier ein bisschen zu bedenken. Sehr hübsche Idee im Übrigen, so ein T-Shirt, ein Freak Show T-Shirt mit so einem typischen Rockband-Tour-Shirt-Design, wo irgendwie hinten alle 200 Folgen aufgeführt sind.
Ja, stand auch das Datum dazu eigentlich oder nur die Nummer?
Die Nummer und der Name auf jeden Fall reicht mein Kabel so weit, ja.
Weil bei so Tour-T-Shirts steht ja auch das Datum drauf, ne?
Da steht das Datum drauf und, das ist nicht alles, es steht die Sendungslänge auch drauf.
Oh, hat dir jemand ganze Arbeit geleistet. Sehr gut. Also wir haben auf jeden Fall mehr auf unserem Tour-T-Shirt als die Rolling Stones.
In den letzten paar Jahren schon. Also davor wahrscheinlich eher nicht.
Also seit es die Freak Show gibt, haben die, ob die Roll...
Aber wir haben auf jeden Fall definitiv längere Sendungen als die Rolling Stones.
Ich weiß nicht, ich war noch nicht auf so einem Konzert.
Na ja, eine Stunde, anderthalb üblicherweise. Ja gut, als Hauptang mal zwei Stunden.
Anfang 90 inzwischen, die können ja so lange. Okay, 70 vielleicht.
Also ich finde, Black Sabbath hat auch fast zwei Stunden gespielt. Black Sabbath hat glaube ich auch fast zwei Stunden in der Bühne letztes Jahr zum Abschlusskonzert gemacht.
Ich habe irgendwann mal die Ärzte gesehen, die sind dann tatsächlich ohne Vorgruppe aufgetreten und haben drei Stunden gemacht, aber das ist echt extrem.
Mein nächstes Konzert war einer meiner Lieblingsbands, Brian Jonestown Massacre und die sind auf die Bühne gekommen und meinten, it's hard to play every night und hatten alle eine Flasche Jack Daniels oder sowas in der Hand und ich dachte mir, Gott, was wird das jetzt werden? Und die haben dreieinhalb Stunden gespielt und am Ende konnte das Publikum nicht mehr. Die konnten nicht mehr und das Konzert endete mit einem zehnminütigen Verstärkerfeedback, bis dann das ganze Publikum zur Bühne kam, alle die Hand geschüttelt hat und erschöpft nach draußen warteten. Das war wirklich so das Beste. Da hat keiner mehr nach Zugabe gerufen und die wären auch nicht mehr in der Lage gewesen dazu. Das war zu rufen.
Ich habe das einmal erlebt, dass eine Band, nachdem das Saallicht schon an war, noch mal rauskam und noch ein Song gespielt hat.
Das war auch sehr strange.
Das waren die Ears.
Es gibt so schöne Konzertmomente auch. Eine kurze Anekdote noch. Ich war ja mal früher beim Oasis-Konzert und alle wollten halt Wonderwall hören und die waren ja schon immer so gegen jeden so, die wollten ja nicht so die Anbieternden sein und dann haben sie das ganze Konzert gespielt und haben nicht Wonderwall gespielt und dann, als die von der Bühne gegangen sind und das Licht anging, dann kam Wonderwall von der CD quasi eingespielt. Das war schon ziemlich wies.
Ich habe einmal eine Band erlebt, ich weiß nicht, ob ich das schon mal erzählt habe. Da war so ein Typ in der ersten Reihe, der so penetrant ausziehen, ausziehen, ausziehen geschrien hat und der Sänger irgendwann, ja, wenn du Bock hast, komm nach oben. Und dann haben die ihn auf die Bühne geholt und dann hat er tatsächlich einen Strip hingelegt, so einmal ganz komplett. Und sowohl die Band als auch das Publikum alle so, was passiert da jetzt eigentlich gerade? Das Schlimmste war eigentlich, dass er dann… Also das Schlimmste war eigentlich, dass er dann zwei Tage später in der Mathe-Vorlesung in der Reihe hinter mir saß, wo ich dann so dachte, oh nein.
Ich war nicht auf so vielen Konzerten.
Muss ja nicht viel sein.
Der Schönste ist ja mal relativ.
Kann ja auch eins gewesen sein, aber das ist das Schönste.
Fällt mir jetzt gerade nicht so ein.
Also mein allerschönstes war, das letzte Konzert von David Bowie gesehen zu haben, als er in Berlin war. Und da habe ich mir gesagt, das erste Konzert, das ist schon eine Weile her, aber da habe ich mir tatsächlich danach gedacht, wenn der nochmal kommen würde, dann würde ich jeden Preis für das Ticket bezahlen. Normalerweise bin ich ja so ab so einem gewissen Konzertticketpreis, sag ich einfach, lass mal gut sein. Aber für den hätte ich tatsächlich gerne nochmal viel ausgegeben, ja.
Lustigweise war ich auch auf zwei Bowie-Konzerten, irgendwie so 2002 oder 2003 oder so in dem Pel.
Und der Mark Schmähling hatte war das letzte. Und die Vorband waren die Dandy Warholz und die waren richtig schlecht.
2003 war es sicherlich nicht das letzte, oder?
Weiß ich nicht mehr. Schon zu lange her, leider.
Ein Special Moment gab es da nicht, das waren alles Standardkonzerte, da ist jetzt nichts aufgefallen, glaube ich.
Ja, ja, ja, ja, es ist so Chili-Veydan jetzt.
Ich nutze mal die kurze Pause für einen kleinen Themen-Gretchen. Ich meine, die ganze Zeit, Monter hin und her, das ist ja hier gar kein roter Faden zu erkennen im Wesentlichen. Und zwar gibt es ein Spiel, und das ist analog, also im Moment, man muss sagen, es gibt eine App, man kann das auch quasi übers Internet mit anderen spielen, aber ursprünglich ist es ein Kickstarter-Gesellschaftsspiel und ich kenne leider nicht mehr genau die Story von dem Typen, der sich dieses Spiel ausgedacht hat, aber die essentielle Nachricht ist, es ist ein tolles Spiel. Es geht so ein bisschen in die Richtung von Mau Mau Uno oder was auch immer, aber nur so grob, aber es sind so Karten, man hat die in der Hand und legt die dann so hin und dann passiert irgendwas und das Spiel heißt Exploding Kittens und eigentlich, hätte ich gedacht, weil das wirklich ein riesen Hype war damals, ich glaube vor zwei Jahren oder so, als dieses Spiel rauskam oder das Kickstarter erfolgreich war, hat irgendwie gefühlt die ganze Welt davon gesprochen und jetzt habe ich aber in letzter Zeit festgestellt, es haben extrem viele Leute noch nie von diesem Spiel gehört, inklusive der gesamten Freak Show Belegschaft, richtig?
Ich habe nur gesehen, dass du irgendwas getwittert hast, ob man das in Düsseldorf gebraucht hat.
Ja, das Ding war nämlich, ich war bei so einem Firmen-Event in Düsseldorf und auf dem Rückweg hatte eine Kollegin dieses Spiel dabei und wir saßen so in so einem schönen Viererabteil und zwei Kollegen hatten eigentlich keinen Bock und der eine meinte sogar, ich hasse Spiele. Viererabteil? Nein, hier so Tisch mit vier Sitzplätzen halt im Großraum, aber so und dann hat sie das halt rausgeholt und wir haben eine Runde so testweise gespielt und es waren sofort alle richtig hart dabei, also so richtig, okay noch eine Runde, sofort, keine Pause, wir spielen das jetzt nochmal und dann musste ich leider mit dem einen Kollegen aussteigen, weil wir in Dortmund noch Leute besucht haben, aber die eine Stunde Zugfahrt von Düsseldorf nach Dortmund verging wie im Fluge und dann war ich beim Kumpel mit Familie und so weiter und eigentlich wollte ich dieses Spiel kaufen für die und es sah auch gleich nochmal die Leute damit anfixen und es war halt einfach unmöglich in Dortmund dieses Spiel zu bekommen. Und zwar, jetzt ist der interessante Teil da dran, bevor wir ins eigentliche Spiel nochmal kommen, der Typ hat halt gesagt, ich vertreibe das selber, also ich mach ne Exploding Kittens Limited und ich gehe nicht zu einem Verlag oder zu irgendeiner Firma, die das Spiel dann lizenziert und dann weiterverkauft, sondern wenn du das Spiel haben willst, kannst du das von mir in Masse auch direkt beziehen, das heißt, wenn du bei Amazon dieses Spiel kaufst, dann kommt das halt von seiner Firma und nicht von irgendeinem anderen Laden. Jetzt bist du in Dortmund und ich war das erste Mal seit Jahren in so einem Spielwarenladen. Also so richtig große auch, ich weiß nicht mehr wie er heißt, aber du denkst ja so...
So wie Toys R Us oder so was?
Ja, nicht so eine große Kette, sondern wirklich so ein guter Sortiertespielladen. Und dann gehst du da so rein und sagst so, ja guten Tag, ich hätt gern so ein Spiel, so Exploding Kittens. Und die so, ist das von Ravensburger oder von was auch immer noch, andere große Spielerverlag oder Firma? Und dann siehst du schon, wie die Augen kurz zucken und so, dann war auch die Antwort, ja also wenn das nicht von Ravensburger oder anderer Dingsbums ist, dann, also wir kriegen das halt vom Großhändler. Und dann mein ich so, na ja, ich dachte halt, wir gehen jetzt in so ein Spielwarenladen, wo ja offensichtlich hoffentlich auch eine Leidenschaft fürs Spielen existiert und dann dachte man halt, so ein großer Erfolg wie dieses Spiel, das dürfte doch an einem nicht vorbeigegangen sein und dann so gab es nur so einen Schulterzug, also ja, also wenn nochmal jemand fragt, dann gucken wir uns das vielleicht nochmal an. Und dann habe ich ganz Dortmund abtelefoniert nach Spiele-Läden und kein Laden hatte das, weil die es halt alle irgendwie von Großhändlern oder Verlagen oder wie auch sonst was beziehen. Konnte ich also in Dortmund nicht spielen, aber jetzt habe ich es mir halt bestellt und ich kann das wirklich nur sehr empfehlen, also es macht einfach Hölle Spaß, es sieht total simpel und banal aus und ich war auch am Anfang, als ich das erste Mal vor die Nase gesetzt habe, da dachte ich so, okay, irgendein Kartenspiel, was soll, mit Katzen, okay. Und wenn du die Special Edition oder die Limited Edition kaufst, die es noch gibt, dann machst du auch die Kiste auf und die macht Miau.
Hey, aber da steht, this box like 99% of boxes does not Miau.
Genau, das ist die Standard Edition, aber es gibt die Limited Edition auch noch im Store zu kaufen und die macht Miau. Na du hast das schon gecheckt, genau.
Ja, das ist das, was ich gesehen habe und ich habe mir gedacht, oh meine Welt bricht zusammen.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht, inwieweit das Sinn macht, das Spiel jetzt hier in epischer Breite auszurollen, aber es kostet nicht viel, es macht wirklich viel Spaß. Es gibt es nur in Englisch, wenn ihr also irgendwie Kids habt, dann müssen die halt mal kurz erklärt bekommen, was halt die Exploding Kitten ist und die Diffuse Kitten und die Rainbow Kitten und was die alle so machen und dann macht das aber richtig Borg.
Es gibt noch ein Expansion Kit, Imploading Kitten.
Und es gibt die Not Safe For Work Edition, wo die Katzen alle sehr vulgäre Posen einnehmen und aber trotzdem sehr putzig sind. Es gibt auch eine App, also man kann das...
Und Plüschtiere.
Genau, es ist auf jeden Fall mega süß, wenn du die App runterlädst, egal Android oder iPhone, dann kann man sozusagen das Remote spielen. Allerdings finde ich, also es ist auch gut, aber das Kartenspiel ist wirklich besser. Ja, das wollte ich mal erwähnen, weil es gibt sicherlich unter euch so irgendwie Leute, die gerne mal auch so ein analoges Spiel mit Leuten spielen.
Aber ich hab mir überhaupt noch nicht verstanden, was das denn das Ziel dieses Spiels ist.
Dass du nicht explodierst.
Man ist selber eine Katze.
Ne, ne, ne, also es gibt einen Stapel Karten mit Katzen drauf und auf N-1 Karten, also N ist die Anzahl der Mitspieler, auf N-1 Karten sind Explo... Also ne, es gibt N-1 Exploding Kittens dann. Also wenn vier Leute spielen, gibt es drei Exploding Kittens im Stapel und das Ziel ist, der letzte Überlebende zu sein. Wenn du nämlich in so eine Exploding Kitten Karte ziehst, dann explodierst du, es sei denn, du hast noch eine Diffuse Kitten. Und dann darfst du, dass einmal, wo du diese Diffuse Karte hast, kannst du die Exploding Kitten wieder in den Stapel stecken und zwar in eine Position, die der gerade recht ist. Wenn du besonders fies bist, guckst du deinem Nachbarn in die Augen und legst sie einfach oben auf den Stapel. Wenn du die Spannung hochhalten willst, packst du es unter den Tisch und schiebst sie an eine, den Mitspielern unbekannte Position. Aber es gibt halt sehr viele Twists in diesem Spiel, wo zum Beispiel, es gibt eine Shuffle Karte. Das heißt, wenn nur der eine legt jetzt so eine Exploding Kitten rein und denkst du so, du Arsch, hast du sie bestimmt jetzt ganz oben hingelegt. Alles klar, ich leg jetzt eine Shuffle Karte, misch den Stapel und dann ist so einer der Klassiker bei dem Spiel, dass du dann trotzdem eine Exploding Kitten ziehst, weil du halt dir eine von den anderen nach oben gemischt hast. Das ist einfach wirklich so von, dieses Mensch ärgere dich nicht Prinzip und ich wirke dir noch eine rein. Genau, eigentlich die schönste Karte ist auch die Nope-Karte. Also es gibt eine Nope-Kitten, und die darf nicht nur der Legen, der jetzt gerade dran ist, sagen wir mal, Dennis legt jetzt die C2-Karten-Kitten, kannst du jetzt als der, der dran ist, einfach sagen Nope, das können alle machen. Das heißt, wenn Letty den Dennis steckern will und ich aber Dennis nicht gestänkert sehen will, dann kann ich auch einfach, der gar nicht dran ist, so eine Nope-Karte einfach dazwischen legen. Aber wenn Letty auch eine Nope-Karte hat, dann kann sie die wieder mit der Nope-Karte kontern. Es gibt einfach so eine geile Fisimatentendynamik und halt multidimensional quasi. Es ist großes Kino und auch der Typ, der Kollege, der meinte, ich hasse Spiele, das meinte er bestimmt nur im Spaß, hallo Daniel, der fand das dann auch richtig geil und fand es sehr schade, dass wir aussteigen mussten und wir nicht mehr weiterspielen konnten. Die Special Edition, die Miau macht, die kostet glaube ich auch 10 Euro mehr, aber ich musste die unbedingt haben, weil das ist einfach geil, wenn du die Kiste aufmachst und Miau.
Ah hier, Limited Edition Miauing Box.
Genau und das schönste, der Typ, ich muss nochmal die Hintergrundgeschichte von dem recherchieren, weil der glaube ich schon auch ein cooler Typ ist, wenn du das bestellst in dem Store auf der Webseite und nicht bei Amazon, dann gehst du durch den ganzen Bestellprozess und ja, wo willst du das hinliefern lassen, wie willst du bezahlen, blablabla und dann ist so der Button, um das zu bestätigen, einem dann, ne wie war das, ah fuck, jetzt hab ich's wieder vergessen, aber es geht so nach dem Motto, ok, ich bin fertig, Zeit nach draußen zu gehen, dann klickst du so, ok, ich bin fertig, Zeit nach draußen zu gehen und es öffnet sich eine Google Map mit Parks in deiner Anschriftumgebung sozusagen und einem Wetterbericht.
Ich verstehe, die haben einen Humor auf jeden Fall. Aber wenn man hier in den USA ordert, wie lange dauert das?
Ne, ne, das kommt aus England.
Ach so, England, wirklich? Guck an.
Also jetzt zugreifen, solange es noch Europreise und so da gibt.
Vor dem Brexit noch schneller.
Also es wurde heute schon geschippt und sollte, ich hab's heute geklickt und sollte hoffentlich noch diese Woche ankommen. Also das ist meine Spieleempfehlung, total analog und der jetzt sagt hier, einer 25 Euro für ein Kartenspiel ist ein sportlicher Preis. Ey, der Spaß, den du mit diesem Spiel hast, ist unbezahlbar, Nummer eins. Und zweitens gebe ich es lieber so einem Typen und statt so einem Ravensburger Verlag, der die letzten, weiß nicht, Disney-Movies oder so in irgendwelche sinnlosen Spiele konvertiert oder was auch immer. Also ich hab ja dieses Spiel der Regalen mir dann auch mal angeguckt, in diesem Spiel, war ein Laden echt ein Trauerspiel. Und dann hatten sie noch diese billig, wie heißen die, Fidget Spinner rumlegen, die geeiert haben. Dieser Laden hat mich tiefst enttäuscht. Sie können von dem weg sprechen, dass ich den Namen nicht mehr weiß.
Also ich glaube, die in Kreuzberg, der Laden Spielbrett heißt der glaube ich in der Nahe Südstern, die könnten das zum Beispiel haben, weil die sind relativ breit aufgestellt und da merkst du auch, dass die gerne auch exotischere Spiele haben.
Ach, ihr sagt gerade jemandem, dass das von dem Oatmeal-Typen ist mit dem Tesla Museum. Das könnte natürlich erklären, warum das so lustig ist. Ja, da war ich mir auch gar nicht so sicher. Oder ich hatte diese Assoziation auch schon mal, aber ich war mir nicht sicher. Ist denn dieser Oatmeal-Typ auch aus England?
Die Zeichnungen sehen halt schwer danach aus.
Okay, dann hat sich hiermit der Kreis geschlossen.
Matthew Inman.
Ja, seine Comics haben ja auch schon viel Freude bereitet. Insofern gebe ich dem auch gerne mal ein paar Euros, damit er weiter Quatsch produziert.
Definitiv derselbe Style. Habe ich aber noch nicht so viel konsumiert, Oatmeal, muss ich zugeben.
Es ist nicht ganz so dicht wie XKCD, aber der hat schon auch coole Sachen. Zum Beispiel das mit dem Mantis Shrimp, dass der Hype da so losgetreten wurde, das war ja auch mit, ich glaube von ihm mit assoziiert, mit losgetreten. Und seine Nikola Tesla Comics und so sind ja auch sehr berühmt.
Ja, gut, schöne Empfehlung.
Wollen wir noch ein bisschen mehr über Max reden?
Können wir machen.
Gibt es was?
Hör mir, ich bin ständig die Spotlight-Suche mit dem neuen Dreckding, hast du das auch?
Die Spotlight-Suche mit dem neuen Dreckding.
Bei mir funktioniert ja manchmal die Tastatur nicht, aber ich glaube, das habe ich dir auch schon mal erzählt, Hucke. Und du hast dann gesagt, ich nutze Alfred.
Ich habe, ich habe, warte mal. Naja, also fast.
Ja doch.
Die liegen zumindest schon mal auf dem Tisch. Jetzt muss ich sie nur noch köpfen. Ja, de-litten. Genau, morgen trifft dann auch mal mein De-Litter ein, mein Spezial-Tool. Habe ich lange darauf warten müssen.
Und hoffen wir auch, dass es passt, weil die CPU steht eigentlich gar nicht dabei.
Naja, gut.
Die Sockelform ist halt eine andere. Also ich meine, da sind die Sockelformen. Naja, andere CPUs haben einen anderen Sockel von der Größe her und das heißt, die sind eventuell auch physikalisch anders von der Größe und dann kann sein, dass der da nicht reinpasst.
Na gut, das werde ich dann morgen feststellen.
Ja, wenn nicht, müssen wir doch mit einem Schraubstock.
Ansonsten müssen wir doch noch mit einem Schraubstock ran. Aber du meintest auch, man muss hier nochmal richtig mit einem Bunsenbrenner aufhalten.
Naja, den Bunsenbrenner nicht, aber wenn ich es richtig gelesen habe, dann ist...
Sauerstoffland.
Dann ist dieser Heap-Spreader, ist halt, also bei den fetteren CPUs, ist er halt nicht nur so außenrum so ein bisschen mit Plaste irgendwie verklebt und berührt einfach nur irgendwie drinnen mit so ein bisschen Wärmeleitpaste das Die, sondern ist das Die tatsächlich mit so einem, ja, verlötet, aber nicht so Lötzchen, wie wir es kennen, was, keine Ahnung, bei 180 Grad oder sonst wo schmilzt, wo man so ein 300 Grad Lötkolben braucht, sondern so ein Zeug, was irgendwie bei 80 Grad oder 90 Grad so schmilzt. Das heißt, wenn man so einen Föhn hat, der ein bisschen heißer kann, ich weiß ja nicht, was so ein Föhn vorne so direkt an der Spitze rauskommt, das könnte schon ganz schön ordentlich was sein.
Kannst du einen normalen Föhn nehmen, also der ist schon heiß.
Ja, dann könnte es sein, dass zumindest dieses Lötzchen so weich wird, dass der Delitter mit seiner physikalischen Kraft so den Rest macht. Aber so ganz ohne Wärme, also im Kalten würde ich das jetzt nicht machen, glaube ich. Vielleicht würde da schon ein bisschen Temperatur drauf geben.
Tja, ich bin gespannt.
Dann ruf mich einfach an, wenn das Ding da ist, dann komme ich vorbei. Hast du denn schon einen langen Inbus-Schlüssel, um in den Kühlkörpern reinzugehen? Die sind so lang, du brauchst so einen langen Inbus. Kann ich nämlich dann mitbringen.
Achso, du meinst um diesen?
Ja, da sind vier Schrauben im Kühlkörper und die sind ja so tief. Du brauchst dann einen relativ langen. Den hat man normalerweise nicht.
Weiß ich jetzt nicht, ob der, also ich habe Inbus, aber ob die jetzt lang genug sind?
Das ist wahrscheinlich nur diese Standardlänge, die ist zu kurz, kann ich dir schon sagen. Hucke, du kennst das.
Ja, ich hatte die Proxxon-Inbus-Schlüssel, die waren lang genug.
Ja, und ansonsten habe ich hier diese Mac OS Beta installiert. Hast du das auch gemacht?
Ja, ich habe das auch gemacht auf eine externe Festplatte per USB oder Fireware 800. Ich habe hin und her gewechselt, hat beides funktioniert. Hat super installiert. Ich habe selber gar nicht lange benutzt zum Testen, weil ich habe dann gleich gesagt, okay, ich will jetzt APFS da drauf haben. Habe ich geklickt, hat er gemacht, ging total rattenschnell für eine Festplatte. Hat mich echt gewundert. Aber booten konnte er dann nicht davon, weil er den Bootloader irgendwie nicht so richtig einträgt. Da kam dann auch immer so eine komische Fehlermeldung, dass er den Bootcash-Helper irgendwie konnte da irgendwie nicht machen und deswegen kann ich da nichts auswählen und nicht davon booten. Andere haben es wohl hinbekommen. Also es ist so eine Glückssache, ob es das mal geht oder nicht, aber bei mir hat es bisher noch nicht geklappt. Muss ich mal gucken, wenn ich nach Hause komme. Aber das APFS an sich, diese Konvertierung hat 1A funktioniert. Ich habe das vorher auch durchgecheckt und so. In meinem normalen Mac kommt das auch, weil der ja schon APFS erkennt. Also das kann man auch alles sehen, nur booten kann ich jetzt nicht davon, nicht mehr. Deswegen an sich, das OS habe ich jetzt nicht viel getestet, aber dieser Wechselvorgang geht auf jeden Fall smooth über die Bühne.
Ja, also er hat auch eine neue Firmware eingespielt, was nicht überraschend ist.
Na bei meinem Rechner nicht.
Ne? Okay, bei meinem 2000…
Ne, weil das mein Mac Pro war, da gibt es keine neue Firmware.
Okay, also bei dem 2009er iMac gab es eine.
Echt? Das ist ja ein Ding.
Na, man muss ja auch davon booten können.
Naja, also wenn ich das richtig gelesen habe, da kommt so ein Spruch, dass sie halt in diese EFI Boot Partition, dass sie da ein EFI Punkt APFS Modul da mit reinschmeißen und aus diesem EFI Boot Partition wird ja eh erstmal geladen, dann zieht da sich auch gleich da den Treiber raus und dann legen sie mit dem Rest irgendwie los. So habe ich das verstanden. Meint der ja Roddy auch schon mal, dass es gar nicht die Firmware können muss.
Ja gut, kann ja sein, dass es dem iMac irgendeinen Bug noch schlummerte.
Oder dass halt die Geräte, die es können, schon direkt booten, aber so ältere halt nicht. Vielleicht ist das ja, was ich erzähle, auch nur für die älteren Kisten, wo sie keine neue Firmware machen.
Ja, wobei jetzt 2009, also so ein richtig neues Modell, ist das ja auch nicht gerade.
Das stimmt. Mein Mac Pro so gesehen ist ja aus dem gleichen Jahr.
Das war ein gutes Jahr. 2009, das war eine reiche Apfel-Ernte.
Wo die Vögel sangen, die Sonne schien.
Das war wirklich schön.
Und die Äpfel blühten.
Bis 2013 hat es gehalten.
Wobei, ich habe das ja hier auch kurz mal von meinem Laptop hier installiert, also auch auf dieses externe Ding. Da müsste der ja auf meinem Laptop ja meine Firmware geupdatet haben. Gesehen habe ich davon nichts. Aber meine Firmware ist jetzt hier. Welche meinst du? Diese SMC-Version?
Wie, was meinst du denn jetzt? Du redest von deinem MacBook Pro, ich rede von meinem iMac.
Ja, ich weiß, aber vielleicht hat der ja auch eine Firmware-Update gemacht, aber ich kann jetzt nicht.
Wo sieht man die?
Weil ich die alte, die alte Nummer... Achso, ich habe hier 2.38 F7. Gehst du mal in den Bau des Mac, dann...
Lässt sich doch nicht miteinander vergleichen, oder?
2.38 F7.
Ja, dann hat sich da noch nix geflasht hier. Aber das Ding ja selbst ja auch noch nicht geupdatiert, das Mac Pro. Das hat ja einen anderen Rechner. Ich habe nur von hier gestartet, aber ich weiß nicht, ob der das dann auch macht oder nicht.
Auf jeden Fall hat er so nach einer halben Stunde Rummenelei und Starten von Mail und anderen Sachen doch signifikant Speicher auch freigegeben. Ich habe hier so eine Terra-Platte drin, die war zur Hälfte voll ungefähr. Und ich glaube, der hat so in etwa 300 Gigabyte sind belegt, 700 sind frei, aber es sind irgendwie mal so 80 bis 90 Gigabyte, die da bei rüber gekommen sind.
Also du hast jetzt APF erst schon gemacht auch?
Ja, Lungen. Klar, es war für mich der Hauptgrund, das jetzt mal auszuprobieren. Ansonsten ist ja jetzt nicht so viel dabei.
Nur Metal 2 vielleicht, weiß nicht, ob man davon was merkt.
Ich habe keine Metal, nicht mal Metal 1-fähige Hardware. Also in dem OS-Update ist jetzt für meine Hardware-Generation eigentlich nix drin.
Und schon hier Time Machine ausprobiert, weil das soll ja wohl der super Bringer sein.
Ehrlich gesagt noch nicht so richtig.
Hast du den APFS-Vortrag gehört von der WWDC? Ja, da war so ein cooler Spruch, da meinte er, ja hier jetzt alles viel einfacher und so. Eigentlich wäre das Time Machine-Team nur damit beschäftigt, jetzt die 10.000 Zeilen Code wieder zu entfernen. Diese brauchten, um eine ganze Snapshot-Reihe irgendwie zu machen, was jetzt ja dank APFS irgendwie von alleine geht.
Ja, wobei sie da jetzt nur von Local Time Machine gesprochen sind.
Ja klar, aber trotzdem cool.
Ja, aber das war ja auch zu erwarten.
Das ist ja wohl das Mindeste.
Also, jede andere Geschichte hätte mich da so ein bisschen überrascht. Insofern haben sie da halt einfach mal das Richtige getan, wenn auch etwas spät.
Das ist ja auch eigentlich für den Endnutzer das, glaube ich, offensichtlichste oder wo er meist merkt, dass er ein neues File System hat, weil ich meine, sonst kriegt man ja von diesem Ding nicht so viel mit. Ich glaube, Local Copies von Files macht man jetzt nicht so oft, aber dieses Time Machine und dass das jetzt alles deutlich besser flutschen müsste, das sollte der End-User schon mitbekommen, das ist schon ein Gewinn.
Local Copies macht man nicht so oft?
Nee, machst du Local Copies oft? Also so Apple DM-Finder, das ist ja das, was Sie damit meinen.
Ja, also nicht täglich, nein, aber das Ding ist, man macht es ja vor allem deshalb nicht, weil sie so viel Platz brauchen.
Nee, warum soll ich eine Datei zweimal haben, also wann macht man denn sowas? Designer machen sowas, ihr habt noch keine Version Systems und so weiter?
Also hier kann man nicht, ich bin keiner, aber wenn du auf…
Bist du kein Designer?
Schau in ihre Augen.
Wenn du auf den Dateien arbeitest, wo du zum Beispiel Wireframes zeichnest, für irgendwie ein Projekt, machen viele sich eine Kopie und zeichnen lassen diesen Ursprungszustand, der mal vielleicht gut war.
Verstehe so.
Und dann darauf weiter auf dem anderen zu arbeiten.
Poor Man's Version Control.
Und das andere Problem ist, Git kann keine Binary Diffs. Das heißt, wenn du Photoshop, also pixelbasierte Dateien hast, dann… Aber es ist halt… Ja, es ist halt nicht so easy.
Ich habe mal in einem Team gearbeitet, da gab es ein Design-Repo, das war dann irgendwann 7 Gigabyte groß und das zu clonen war nicht so ganz einfach.
Das war mein Kumpel Toppen, die haben einen Comic-Film in SVN gedingst, war noch mehr als 40 Gigabyte am Ende groß.
Ich glaube, mich zu erinnern, dass es tatsächlich mal irgendwie Versuche gab, so ein Version-Control-System zu bauen für pixelbasierte Grafikdateien, aber ich habe da nie wieder was von gehört und dementsprechend ist es vollkommen vom Radar verschwunden.
Ich weiß, dass GitHub in der Tat daran arbeiten wollte.
Achso, die haben Diffs für pixelbasierte Dateien, aber das Version-Control-System unterstützt halt keine Deltas von Binary-Data, d.h. du kriegst immer die volle Kopie.
Na, was GitHub gemacht hat, war Big-Big-Binary-Data zu unterstützen.
Ja, das geht auch. Aber sie können halt auch Diffs, also du kannst halt einen Diff von Bild-Dateien dir angucken und dann zeigen sie dir einen Diff.
Ich weiß, ich mache das fast täglich.
Also Tim, ich würde an deiner Stelle diese Schokolade wieder in ihre Original-Hülle packen, sonst weißt du demnächst mal irgendwann nicht, was es ist oder irgendwer anders, wer hier mal putzen kommt und sich mal ein Stück klauen will und dann stirbt dir einer weg.
Ich würde auf jeden Fall eine davon klauen und mitnehmen.
Ein Stück?
Pumsi, deinem...
Nein, ein Stück würde ich auch nehmen, glaube ich. Hast du Alufolie? Zum Einpacken. Ich...
Hol ich dann Dennis.
Wir werden dann den Besuch finden. Zurück zu APFS. Ich habe dann ein bisschen beobachtet, wie sich denn das so verhält, weil also, also erstmal, das mit dem Kopieren ist für mich schon ein Ding, weil ich habe schon öfter mal so eine Situation, wo ich mir denke, oh, jetzt starte ich hier mal so einen Skript, File Conversion, weißt du, läuft über so einen ganzen Ordner rüber, das sind dann auch viele Dateien und dann willst du aber irgendwie das danach auch wieder wegschmeißen können, weil du nie weißt, ob es geklappt hat und du möchtest halt gerne so, aber dann sind das halt so. Dann kann ich halt entweder einen Snapshot machen oder ich mache halt mal eine lokale Kopie, was ja auch die Möglichkeit bietet, dass man dann mehrere Skripte parallel in irgendwelchen Sachen laufen lässt, alles Mögliche. Jetzt ist das aber eine Option, wo es vorher halt keine Option war, insbesondere wenn du nicht mehr genug Speicher hast oder wenn das Kopieren einfach zu lange dauert.
So ein Snapshot-Button gibt es nicht für das File-System, also eigentlich die Features sind noch nicht so exposed, was es so kann, nach außen übers GUI.
Also gibt es nicht im User-Interface, aber gibt es auf der Kommandezahle.
Und genauso wenig gibt es ja den schönen Solaris-Time-Slider im Finder. Ach so den von diesen, hm, den hätte ich mir sehr gewöhnt.
Kommt ja vielleicht noch irgendwann.
In diesem Betriebssystem, siehst du Solaris, ne? Schon so lange her. Die hatten ja auch ZFS, also da kommt das ja her quasi und da hatten die so einen Slider einfach im Finder oder im File Manager, wo du halt einfach die Snapshots so hin und her schieben konntest. Das war sehr geil.
Ja und das im Fenster hat sich dann live dementsprechend geupdatet, ne? Haben die ja, mehr oder weniger ist ja dieses Time Machine Fenster, was da so durch den Weltort durch die Sterne ist ja sowas nur ein bisschen anders angeordnet, aber im Großen und Ganzen kommt das dem ja schon sehr nahe und ist ja wahrscheinlich auch von da geklaut, das ist ja nicht...
Tja, also wenn ich jetzt hier TMUtil-Snapshot mache, kriege ich ein Failed-to-create-lookes-snapshot. Ja, keine Ahnung, was hier schief geht.
Man nennt es Beta-Version.
Wollte schon sein. Aber so dieser Effekt mit, ich nehme einen großen Ordner und mache mir mal eine Kopie davon, probiere ich mal aus hier, 99 Gigabyte, zack.
Was ich interessant fand, als ich in einer Emergency-Partition war oder Recovery-Partition-Boot gemacht habe und da den Disk Utility ausgewählt habe, um die Platte mal jetzt frisch zu formatieren, um das mit dem Installer normal zu probieren, weil ich ja mit dem Boot ein Problem hatte, hat er mir ZFS angeboten. Hab ich probiert, hat natürlich nicht funktioniert, aber das war als Auswahl da, um diese Platte zu formatieren.
Aber vielleicht, weil du noch die ZFS Extension irgendwo rumliegen hattest?
Nee, ich habe ja von der Recovery Partition.
In der Recovery Partition unwahrscheinlich.
Stimmt.
Hat mich ein bisschen gewundert.
Aber es kann sein, dass sie die Partitions-Dings, den Code immer noch irgendwie drin haben.
Und dass das ein Fehler ist, dass sie das beim Formatieren nicht auflisten dürften.
Das hat ja auch nicht geklappt, also ich denke mal, es ist ja auch das A-F-P-S in Wirklichkeit ZFS. Sondern sie rappen es nur.
Nee, dann hätten sie aber Check-Summing, was sie ja nicht haben, was ich ihnen ja immer noch schwer ankreide. Da bin ich ja noch nicht so überzeugt von.
Ja, das verstehe ich auch nicht so richtig, was ich da vorhabe.
Aber wenn sie mit dem Snapshotting das mit dem Time Machine schon deutlich besser machen, das wäre schon eine mega Nummer, weil Backup geht nicht mehr ohne. Und da ich ja Triple Backupper bin... Was machst du gerade? Hast du Local Copy gemacht? Jetzt kopiert er doch.
Ja, also naja.
Bist du sicher, dass du AFPS hast?
Genau, das ist nämlich nicht Default.
Oder APFS?
Bei so einem alten Ding.
Ja, ja, ich bin mir sicher, dass ich das habe.
Mach doch mal AFVI auf deinen Diskeiken.
Und?
Das ist APFS.
Ich habe jetzt hier mal meine Dropbox genommen, da sind so 100 Gigabyte drin.
Die Dropbox, da musst du ja aus dem Netz holen.
Nein. Ja, bist du Dropbox nicht vertraut? Ja, du musst das nicht aus dem Netz holen, das ist der Sinn von Dropbox, dass du so ein Offline-Storage hast.
Das ist wie Resilio Sync, nur in schlecht.
Also das dauert, äh, ne, das ist, Dropbox ist nicht schlecht. Dropbox ist eigentlich ein sehr cooler Dienst.
32-Bit.
Auch nicht mehr, übrigens.
Habe ich mir gefixt, ja. Haben Sie unsere Sendung gehört?
Äh, also die App ist mittlerweile 64-Bit, aber sie haben noch irgendwie so kleine Demons noch laufen, die noch 32-Bit sind, aber die sind dran. Ich meine, die müssen ja jetzt. Also das geht auf jeden Fall jetzt nicht mal so katzinger, was man ja irgendwie erwarten würde, wenn das ein Ordner ist. Also es ist nicht so, dass er jetzt hier einen Ordner macht, sondern er rappelt jetzt mal schön hier durch 108.000 Items durch. Und erst meint er, es dauert einen Tag, jetzt ist er dabei, es dauert noch fünf Sekunden. Sieht aber irgendwie nach zwei Minuten aus, also so richtig überzeugend, demofähig, finde ich das jetzt noch nicht.
Aber wenn du es aus diesem Dropbox-Ordner raus, also rüber kopiert hast, dann nochmal auf den Desktop supplizieren und dann geht es bestimmt total schnell. Da ist bestimmt irgendwelche Dropbox-Magic noch dazwischen.
Was soll denn da der Unterschied sein?
Ich frage Dropbox.
Wieso was hat das mit Dropbox zu tun?
Hat eine Dropbox nicht auch eine eigene Conextentation gemacht? Vielleicht wird das ausgeschlossen von dem APFS, was du da machst und deswegen dauert das jetzt so lange.
Nein, ich glaube Dropbox hat keine eigene Conextentation mehr. Hier sind jetzt so eine Finder-Extension.
War das nicht mal irgendwie, wo sie erzählt haben, sie machen jetzt hier aufs Bild eine Conextentation?
Eigentlich wollten sie in die Zukunft gehen mit irgendwie Conextentation. Ich weiß jetzt auch nicht so ganz genau. Aber das ist ja kein lokal gemountetes File-System, die Dropbox, sondern das ist ja nur ein Ordner in meinem Home.
Naja, oder da hängt noch irgendwelche Magie dran, die du nicht siehst.
So, so, Magie.
Eigentlich habe ich ja hier alles schick backup, ich update jetzt mal schnell.
Kopier doch mal einen anderen Folder, der nicht Dropbox verwandt ist.
Also ich weiß nicht, Dropbox ist bei mir unten durch, seit sie diesen Login-Fenster hackt da abgezogen haben, wo sie irgendwie das System gebe hier deine Credentials Fenster ein nachgebaut haben, nur um dann an das Passwort zu kommen und mit dem dann was ganz anderes zu machen. Seitdem sind sie so ein bisschen bei mir unten durch. Weil sie aus irgendeinem Grund Accessibility angeschaltet haben wollen für ihre eigene Extension und statt da auf normalem Weg zu battlen, haben sie halt dann das einfach hinten rum angeschaltet.
Haben sie da nicht auch Ärger gekriegt dafür?
Ja, haben sie ohne Ende Ärger dafür bekommen. Haben sie auch zu Recht Ärger dafür bekommen. Aber es ist jetzt nicht so, dass das so eine mega privacy Intrusion war, wie da halt immer behauptet wurde.
Die andere Schokolade musst du jetzt nicht mit dem Skypellen-Mini-Stücke zerteilen, ne?
Aber ich darf trotzdem die Folie mit dem Skypellen zerteilen, oder?
Mit den Zähnen.
Gut. Keine weiteren nennenswerten Erkenntnisse zu dem ganzen APFS-Kram. Und von daher können wir um zum nächsten Thema.
Ich mach das jetzt mal live hier. Ich werde dann berichten, während der Sendung. Wenn er mal schreien hört, dann wird das nicht geklappt.
Aber nicht immer unterbrechen die ganze Zeit.
Also ich kann noch irgendwie iOS 11 berichten, dass ich da so ein bisschen Probleme hatte mit dem Laden von iPads, weil irgendwie irgendwas haben sie an der Laderegelung verbaselt. Und jetzt muss man das Kabel, wenn das im Netzteil steckt mit der USB-Seite und man die Leitningseite einsteckt, dann erkennt er das Kabel nicht und sagt, dieses Zubehör ist nicht unterstützt. Und wenn man es dann aus dem Netzteil wieder raussteckt, während die Leitningseite eingesteckt ist und dann wieder ins Netzteil einsteckt, dann lädt er plötzlich. Ich weiß nicht warum. Eins von den iPads hatte das Problem, dass er irgendwie abgestürzt ist. Dann hing er irgendwie am Strom, hat den Strom nicht erkannt, kam aber nicht mehr hoch und hat sich soweit in eine Spirale des Entladens und Bootens hinein gesteigert, dass er irgendwann halt nur noch diesen roten Akkustreifen gezeigt hat und kein iOS mehr lief. Dann musste ich ihn dann irgendwie auf diverse Art und Weise wieder hochkitzeln. Also ich weiß nicht, ich würde von iOS 11 immer noch so ein bisschen die Finger lassen.
Na gut, ist ja in dem Sinne auch noch nicht draußen. Das ist ja Developer-Kreppel. Was ist denn so dein Gefühl?
Ja, ist schon geil. Ja, das macht schon mehr Laune. Abgesehen davon, dass es jetzt, also ich habe es auf einem iPad R1 drauf und es ist schon langsam. Genauso wie auf dem iPad Mini Retina, das allererste. Gut, das sind jetzt auch keine super frischen Devices mehr, aber so ein iPad bisher habe ich halt auch nicht die Notwendigkeit gesehen, jetzt das iPad zu ersetzen, weil es war irgendwie gut genug für das, was es getan hat. Aber jetzt so mit iOS 11, da ist schon so, irgendwelche Animationen fallen da meistens eher flach, das ist dann mehr so Diavortrag. Wenn man da irgendwo swipet, dann hat man irgendwie zwei Zwischenbilder, bis dann der Zustand erreicht ist und so.
Warum ist denn das, dass es auf einmal so langsam wird?
Keine Ahnung. Ja, vielleicht liegt es auch an der Beta-Version, das kann natürlich sein.
Oder weil die Grafik, die GPU, da schon ein bisschen zu schwach auf der Brust ist?
Das kann auch sein, ja.
Na gut, dann können sie es ja immer noch so machen, wie sie es bisher gemacht haben und war ja auch schnell genug.
Woran ich mich extrem schnell gewöhnt habe, ist die neue Tastatur.
Was ist da anders?
Ja, das sowieso nicht. Nein, du hast ja diese iPad-Tastatur, ist ja wie die iPhone-Tastatur im Prinzip, nur dass alle Tasten größer sind, die alte. Und in der neuen haben sie jetzt auf die Tasten, da ist halt wie auf so einer Schreibmaschinentastatur, halt unten der Buchstabe ohne Shift und oben der Buchstabe mit Shift. Und man macht Shift jetzt, indem man die Taste tappt und nach unten zieht. Und dann bekommst du halt den Buchstaben, der oben ist, oder das Zeichen, was oben ist. Und das ist schon sehr, sehr praktisch, weil man sonst halt immer, immer Shift hier und dann die Zeichen hier und dann das. Man musste da ständig irgendwie immer umschalten.
Das heißt, für Großtippen muss man jetzt nicht mehr extra tippen vorher nochmal?
Für Groß schon, aber halt nicht mehr für die ganzen Sonderzeichen. So Fragezeichen, Ausrufezeichen.
Und machen wir das für die großen Tasten nicht auch? Ein großes A drauf machen und nach unten ziehen? Wär doch so.
Ja, dachte ich jetzt auch.
Nee, aber da kriegst du halt das Sonderzeichen.
Nee, das war doch, wenn man festhält und wartet und dann kommt da oben die Sonderzeichenleiste.
Nein, ja, nein. Also wenn du sowieso schon unten auf Sonderzeichen umgestellt hast, dann hast du, wenn du auf ein Zeichen gegangen bist und gewartet hast, noch eine größere Auswahl an Sonderzeichen bekommen. Und jetzt ist es halt so, dass die Tastatur, also so im Urzustand kannst du halt ein Zeichen tippen, ziehen und bekommst das Sonderzeichen, was normalerweise auf der Sonderzeichenplane wäre, wo du sonst umschalten müsstest.
Kann ich noch nicht so richtig nachvollziehen, weil da kommen ja ganz viele Zeichen, welches kommt dann, wenn ich nach unten ziehe.
Aber es gibt jetzt sozusagen eine bessere Methode, Shift zu machen, also funktioniert das nicht?
Das Zeichen, was Standard wäre, wenn du auf Sonderzeichen umgeschaltet hättest. Also es gibt ja diese 1, 2, 3 Taste unten, wo du umschaltest, wo du die Zahlen bekommst und die ganzen Sonderzeichen. Und alles, was da drauf ist, ist quasi in der Standardversion noch mal zusätzlich drauf, in ein bisschen Grau, und diese Zeichen bekommst du, wenn du runterziehst.
Ich hätte eher gedacht, dass wenn ich bei so einem A runterziehe, dass dann ein großes A kommt, weil das ist ja das, was man am häufigsten braucht, so Großbuchstaben, oder?
Naja, als Nicht-Deutscher eher nicht so.
Wieso?
Ja, weil andere Sprachen nur am Satzanfang groß schreiben und sonst nicht. Also, dass die Deutschen so viele Großbuchstaben verwenden, ist halt einzigartig. Wenn du Englisch tippst, brauchst du kaum Großbuchstaben.
Ein Irrtum.
Ja, du machst Caps Lock an und schreibst alles groß. Aber davon rede ich ja nicht. Normalen Fleece Text.
Auch normaler Fleece Text ist durchsetzt mit Abkürzungen.
The Lazy Dog Jumps Over the... Dingstang, was war das? Crazy?
Ja, du hast auch Titel. Du heißt halt auch... In Überschriften schreibst du im Englischen auch groß. Du hast Abkürzungen ohne Ende. Meine Welt ist voll mit Abkürzungen. Also, ich lass mir die Großbuchstaben nicht schlecht machen und schon gar nicht meinen Caps Lock.
Okay, ich wollte jetzt auch nicht deinen Caps Lock schlecht machen, weil ich weiß schon, dass du dir das nicht schlecht machen lässt. Ich sage nur, dass man im Englischen deutlich weniger Großbuchstaben braucht als im Deutschen. Weil im Deutschen hast du halt alle Substantive, wenn groß, geschrieben. Deswegen hast du halt fürchterlich viele Großbuchstaben drin und deswegen brauchst du als Deutscher deutlich häufiger die Shift-Taste als Englisch-Native-Speaker oder wie auch immer.
Was ich nach dem Vorhang am Kusten fand mit den Tastaturen war, auf meinem heißgeliebten Blackberry, wenn du lange draufgedrückt hast, hast du halt den Großbuchstaben bekommen. Und wenn du dann auf die andere Tastatur gewechselt bist, für die Sonderzeichen, konntest du halt deine Tastatur so benutzen, wie das, was du oben gesehen hast, für die Sonderzeichen. Also da ging das halt nahe. Das Blackberry hatte diese physische Tastatur gehabt. Wenn du auf eine Tasse lange gedrückt hast, hast du entweder den Großbuchstaben bekommen, oder konntest auch oben in der Kontextleiste dir, wie bei Apple jetzt, wenn du lange draufdrückst, diese Umlaute fallen wir auch mit reinholen. Und wenn du dann auf, was jetzt hier bei der alten iPhone Tastatur der Wechsel ist auf die Sonderzeichen mit den Nummern, hast du auch mit so einem Tastaturwechsel bekommen. Du konntest dann aber natürlich die physische Tastatur auch nutzen. Das war irgendwie immer noch am Kusten, vor allen Dingen eben, weil du bei Deutsch häufig das Großbuchstaben gedöhnt brauchst. Ist das halt echt super praktisch, einfach nur lange drauf zu drücken und dann ist der Buchstabe groß?
Nee, ich sag nur, ich find's nicht so verkehrt. Aber naja, das Xcode-Ding auf dem iPad, wie heißt das doch gleich? Playgrounds 2 sieht auch ganz gut aus, aber es ist irgendwie auch nochmal langsamer geworden. Also es ist so richtig langsam, aber da hast du den Gag, dass auf manchen Tasten hast du halt zwei Sonderzeichen, also geschweifte Klammer auf, geschweifte Klammer zu. Und wenn du dann nach unten ziehst, kannst du nach rechts oder nach links ziehen und kriegst dann jeweils entweder auf oder zu von der Klammer. Also im Prinzip her sehr schön, aber unglaublich langsam zumindest auf den Geräten, auf denen ich es bisher ausprobiert hab.
Was ich cool finde, was sie berichtet haben von iOS 11, ist, dass sie jetzt oben in diesem extra Bar anzeigen, wenn die eigene Location abgefragt wird. Dann kommt ja so, wie man früher, wenn noch ein Telefonanruf lief und man in irgendeiner App war, dann war ja das glaube ich in Rot so ein bisschen, da ist hier noch so ein Call irgendwie active.
Apps, die im Hintergrund die Location benutzen, werden als solche angezeigt.
Genau, also richtig...
Das ist der Horror.
Prominent. Wieso ist es der Horror?
Ich finde das gut.
Das heißt, das ist wahrscheinlich eine meiner Lieblings-Apps, die nicht mehr zu benutzen sind.
Ja, dann müssen sie endlich mal lernen, wie man das ordentlich programmiert. Das ist echt nicht so schwer. Selber Apple kriegt es nicht bei allen Apps hin, dass sie das ordentlich irgendwie da anpassen.
Was denn programmieren, was soll man da?
Dass diese Bar, die dann noch so ein Stück runterkommt, die macht ja dein Screen sozusagen ein Stück kleiner. Und wenn du das falsch kodest, dann ist dein Scheiß einfach dahinter, anstatt dass dein Screen ein Stück kleiner wird.
Nee, da vergiss mir nicht, ich will diesen Scheiß Bar nicht sehen.
Ja, das kannst du bestimmt abschalten, oder? Weiß ich nicht.
Davon habe ich nichts gelesen, dass es geht.
Also es ist sicherlich gut gegen all diese Apps, die das einfach machen.
Ja, aber ich habe halt eine App, die ist immer an.
Welche denn?
Vielleicht kannst du die ja exkluden. Und ist dein Telefon immer schön schnell leer?
Ich opfe da Batterie für die Funktion.
Das heißt, du schneidest immer mit, wo du gerade bist. Immer.
Sau praktisch.
Für dein Logbuch.
Wenn man aus der Bar rausfällt und nicht mehr weiß, wo man gestern war.
Du weißt halt immer, wo du dein Auto geparkt hast. Du weißt, ob du zurecht geblitzt wurdest. Du hast einfach Protokoll. Ich habe mir das früher als Kind immer gewünscht. Das war so ein Kindheitstraum von mir. Wenn ich mir so wirklich was richtig gerne gehabt hätte, wäre es so, dass irgendwie so ein Onkel kommt und mir zum Geburtstag die vollständigen Routen jedes Weges, den ich gelaufen bin, in meinem Leben gezeigt hätte. In jedem Urlaub, jeder Ort, wo ich mal war. Das hätte ich wirklich gerne gehabt.
Das hast du jetzt, meinst du? Und das hast du jetzt?
Das habe ich jetzt. Das ist schon ganz cool, wenn man mal ein bisschen zurückblättert. Ich glaube, wenn man mal irgendwo war, findest du alles wieder.
Und man sieht diese Karte mit so einer Linie, und dann so da langfahren, und mit Datumswechsel und so weiter.
Das heißt, du kannst sehen, wenn du vor zwei Wochen von meiner Geburtstagsumtrunkerei...
Ich weiß ganz genau, wo ich da rausgestiefelt bin.
Also sein iPhone weiß es.
Ja, sag mal die Uhrzeit würde ich mal sagen.
Das heißt, dann bei dir, der Horst Tappert ankommt, sagen sie, Herr Pretler, wo waren Sie denn am 24.3. diesen Jahres? Dann hast du gar kein Problem, zack zack rausgeholt und hier, ich war es nicht.
Dann sagt der Harry, hol doch schon mal den Wagen.
Allerdings muss man auch mal wieder ein Update kriegen.
Auch eine 32-Bit-App?
Nee, das nicht, aber es hat irgendwie einen...
Es ist Right Only, du kannst dir zwar alle schreibende Informationen, aber nicht...
Aber du kannst dich exportieren, nur wenn du ordentlich bezahlst.
Ich schlage mal nach, kann sein, dass ich diese Information doch nicht gemeldet habe.
Ist die App was?
Es wäre mal sehr schön, wenn es da mal was Neues gäbe, weil perfekt ist es irgendwie nicht. Ich hätte lieber mal was, was das auch mal so korrekt iCloud-mäßig macht. Ich weiß, das ist alles so privacy-mäßig zu begrenzen.
Aber Musi, meine Location mit Schreiben hört sich doch nach einem relativ easy Tool an, oder?
Ja, aber ich habe kein anderes Tool gefunden, was das so macht.
Nee, aber ich wollte ja damit jetzt unsere arbeitslosen IOS-Programmierer da draußen. Okay, wird es wahrscheinlich keinen geben, der arbeitslos ist, aber...
Nee, es ist ganz schwierig, welche zu finden, aber dazu kommt...
Die jungen Hacker, die vielleicht doch noch keinen Job haben, aber schon ein bisschen IOS testen wollen, dann ist doch mal eine nette App, wo man easy mit anfangen kann. Einfach mal die Location mit Schreiben. Und die coolen Features sind dann halt, in welchen Formen man das alles anzeigt und exportieren kann. Das sind ja die eigentlichen Features an die ich vorgebracht habe.
Also hier schreibt gerade einer im Chat, dass sie zu Facebook gehört. Das Internet bestätigt das auch.
Was?
Board by Facebook?
Nein.
Alles zu Facebook gelockt.
Das heißt, ich darf das auch wegschmeißen.
Und dann kann sie dir jetzt nicht diese Frage beantworten, von wo du vor zwei Wochen...
Nee, weil da lief die App mal wieder nicht wegen Crash-Problematiken. Nee, Crash-Problematiken. Zum Kotz.
Schade.
Ich brauch eine Alternative. Wenn ihr eine Alternative zum Moves kennt, bitte einmal, dann bitte.
Aber wenn man drüber nachdenkt, nicht erstaunlich, dass es gerade Facebook war.
2014 auch schon bereits.
Naja, ich lösche mal meinen Account.
Willkommen bei der Freak Show, wo wir Tim deine Cloud-Welten verstören.
Seine Gadgets wegnehmen.
Hast du auch diesen Moves Export, um dann wirklich deine Daten zu sehen? Eine extra App dafür, dass du sie exportieren kannst?
Nee, das geht über die Webseite.
Ja, das ist ja eigentlich blöd, das muss ja gar nicht über eine Webseite gehen, oder? Das hört sich wirklich an wie ein Tool, was man irgendeinen Jungenhacker quoten könnte, oder? Das muss ja jetzt nicht so schwer eigentlich.
Nö.
Roddy.
Na du musst halt so, hier ist nicht nur um die…
Ich bin kein Jungenhacker mehr.
Du musst halt, also was Moves halt macht, ist, es macht halt so Annahmen über den Ort. Ja, wenn du da irgendwo in der Nähe bist und so. Das ist auch nicht perfekt, aber halt ganz brauchbar. Das heißt, wenn du irgendwo eine Weile verweilst, dann hast du halt nicht Reise, sondern hast du so Blase. Du hältst dich, was weiß ich, eine Stunde an diesem Ort auf und dann bist du wieder gefahren. Und es macht halt auch Annahmen darüber, wie du gefahren bist. Das heißt, in Abhängigkeit von der Geschwindigkeit, sagt es halt gehen oder Fahrradfahren. Also kriegt er wahrscheinlich auch über die Beschleunigungs-Sensoren irgendwie vom System mitgeteilt, was für ein Typ das ist.
Guck dir mal das Pardo an. Das sieht auch gut aus.
Pardo?
Pardo. Deutscher Entwickler Alexander Klaus.
Klingt nach Qualität. Klick mal da auf den Link und schau mal in das User-Interface, ob dir das, ich bin auf deine Reaktion gespannt. Also klick mal da, da siehst du ja schon die Screenshot-Previews.
Tim, hast du jetzt die ganze Schokolade alleine aufgegessen?
Gib mir doch nochmal die Schokolade. Nein, die Schokolade.
Ach so, die Schokolade.
Sag ich doch, die Schokolade.
Aber was ist denn mit dieser Activity-Geschichte von Apple, dieser App? Kann die das nicht?
Nicht so detailliert.
Die trackt ja nur deine Aktivität.
Nö, die tracken auch Location, aber das ist ganz tief unten versteckt irgendwo. Der merkt sich doch überall, wo du warst und so.
Ja, aber das sind auch nur die Frequent Locations, der macht ja Bewegungsprofile.
Das ist jetzt das Pardo, ja?
Ja, das Problem mit diesen meisten Apps ist, und da muss ich jetzt jetzt gerade mal gucken, wie das jetzt hier eigentlich ist, das sind dann so Geo-Tracking, da musst du die App starten und sagen, jetzt tracken.
Ja, du willst aber nicht starten, du willst sagen, immer.
Immer.
Gib ich mir volles Programm.
Lauf einfach, mach, Hals, Maul, Fristbatterie. Mach Fristbatterie, mach mir keine blauen Balken an.
Hals, Maul und Track.
Kann ich das iOS jederzeit irgendwie so eine App beenden? Und was machst du dann? Musst du das Moves dann neu starten? Woher weißt du das?
Solche Apps können sich ja explizit mit so Geofences und so weiter registrieren. Das ist ja wie so eine Navi-App.
Verstehe.
Nur, dass er halt mir nicht sagt, wo ich hingehen soll, sondern einfach nur notiert, wo ich gewesen bin. Und da hab ich irgendwie schon viele Schlüsse draus ziehen können. Wo war ich da nochmal? Wo hab ich meine Jacke vergessen?
Aber es steht da drin, Tim, du hast deine Jacke dort und dort vergessen. Oder kannst du dich dann noch an die Uhrzeit erinnern, wo du eventuell gewesen sein könntest?
Manchmal kann ich mich auch noch an die Uhrzeit erinnern, wo ich irgendwann mal gewesen sein könnte. Naja, ich sehe ja den Verlauf sozusagen. Und man kriegt halt auch einen super... Also, Moves ist eigentlich auf 10% des Weges irgendwie stehen geblieben. Ich benutze das, glaube ich, jetzt auch nur noch, weil ich dachte, sie würden sich nicht von Facebook kaufen lassen. Da fehlt einfach viel. Was ich gerne hätte, ist so ein persönlicher Assistent zur Analyse sozusagen meiner Bewegung. Also nicht nur im Sinne von, wie viel bewege ich mich und Kalorien verbrauche. Das machen die Dinger ja schon alleine. Nö, so dieses bisschen Sesselpupser. Wie viel verbringst du eigentlich an anderen Orten? Was sind die Orte, an denen ich am meisten Zeit verbringe?
Plämpere.
Wie viele Autofahrten habe ich gemacht? Du hast ja im Prinzip mit so was auch gleich ein automatisches, grobes Fahrtenbuch. Woraus du so... Weil wenn das Ding merkt, ich fahre im Auto, muss ich das ja nur noch einem Auto zuordnen. Und dann hätte ich das im Prinzip nebenbei. Oder auch, wie viel Fahrrad fahre ich? Ohne, dass ich jetzt die ganze Zeit immer irgendwie Activity Monitor und jetzt Training starten und super fancy. Ich will einfach nur, dass das mir sagt. Das sind so meine Wünsche.
Weil du das Thema Auto nochmal angebracht hast. Eine Sache ist mir ja, das habe ich ja bei dem Turan noch nicht erwähnt, der hatte CarPlay. Ich habe also das erste Mal CarPlay im Einsatz gehabt. Und was soll ich sagen? Ja, ist ganz nett. Also man muss das nicht unbedingt haben. Die Integration von dem Sound ist halt ganz gut. Weil du kannst halt irgendwie Musik anmachen und Routing irgendwie auf dem Phone und irgendwie die Anlage von dem Auto kriegst, dass das mit, dass es das spielen soll. Und wenn Ruhe ist, dann ist Ruhe, weil kein Radio an ist und so. Also das fand ich ganz nett. Und das iPhone merkt sich, wann du es aussteckst und setzt den Pin, hier ist jetzt mein Auto. Nicht, dass ich das gebraucht hätte, weil das immer direkt vom Ferienhaus stand, aber das fand ich irgendwie auch ganz nett.
Das ist in der Tat ein cooles Feature, weil dann musst du dir nämlich nicht mehr mit einer extra App merken, wo dein Auto geparkt wurde.
Wir wissen, wo dein Auto steht.
Das Feature hätte ich ab und zu wirklich tatsächlich gerne auch normal in der App, also in der MAP-App.
Naja, du hast es halt, wenn du das Phone mit Bluetooth oder anderen Mitteln mit dem Auto verbindest.
Aber können das zum Beispiel Drive Now Autos?
Das weiß ich nicht.
Nein, Quatsch. Falsch Frage. Mit einem Drive Now Auto muss ich nicht wissen, wo ich es geparkt habe.
Das weiß sie.
Und das Kfz, das ich sonst so fahre, das ist auch noch so ein Auto. Das hat zwar schon Elektronik, aber noch keinen Blauzahn.
Also bei dem Turan war das halt so, der hatte halt so relativ prominent neben dem 12 Volt Stromanschluss, wo man früher mal mit Zigaretten angemacht hat mit, hat er halt noch so einen USB-Stecker. Und ich dachte, neuer, dann kannst du das Phone gleich laden, hab das eingesteckt und dann kam CarPlay hoch. Das fand ich schon irgendwie sehr nett. Abgesehen davon, dass das außer den Apple eigenen Apps keine andere App irgendwie dieses CarPlay unterstützt. Das ist ein bisschen doof, wenn du nicht das Apple eigene Routing oder so verwendest.
Aber wer verwendet denn nicht das Apple eigene Routing?
Derjenige, der nach Dänemark fährt und in Dänemark plötzlich keine Bits mehr bekommt.
Ach so, das Problem, was ich ja immer noch habe, ist, ich benutze ja meinen Telefon auf Englisch, also Systemsprache, aber Siri hab ich auf Deutsch eingestellt zwischendurch, weil ich dachte, vielleicht kann ich damit dann die Apple Map Voice auch auf Deutsch bekommen. Das ging lange Zeit nicht, und jetzt haben sie ja neue Stimmen auch hinzugefügt. Und es geht aber immer noch nicht. Ich kriege immer noch die Kaiserin Auguste Straße und die Niesen New Straße und all das Ganze. Und man kann dieses Telefon nicht überzeugen. Und ich hab letztens wirklich weitestgehend, also bei Siri, alles auf Deutsch gestellt, was ich überhaupt in diesen Anstellungen gefunden habe. Aber es wurde immer schlimmer, dann habe ich eine Männerstimme plötzlich bekommen, obwohl ich eine weibliche, deutsche Frauenstimme ausgewählt habe. Also dieses Apple Maps und Stimme ist auch noch so ein kleines Trainwreck. Wenn man nicht das Telefon wahrscheinlich auf Deutsch stellt. Aber das will ich nicht. Aber Google kann ich nicht benutzen aus ethischen Gründen. Nee, ich will so wenig Google wie möglich benutzen. Google Hygiene. Aber ich benutze ja Google zum Googeln. Also das ist ja auch ein Problem.
Also ich habe Google nur einmal benutzt, weil weder Apple noch irgendwie TomTom die Adresse von dem Recyclinghof in Flensburg gefunden hat.
Ja, aber ist es nicht wirklich frappierend, wie schlecht die Straßensuche, diese Ortssuche in Apple Maps immer noch ist?
So schlimm finde ich die nicht.
Die findest du nicht so schlimm?
Das Ding findet nichts. Also Kontext, es ist halt kontextfrei.
Es ist total kontextfrei. Es findet ganz offensichtlich nicht die Straße, in der ich stehe, wenn ich da bin und danach suche.
Du musst halt bei vielen anderen Locations suchen, gibst du halt eine Straße ein und du kriegst die höchstwahrscheinlichsten Ergebnisse. Wenn du in Düsseldorf bist und suchst nach der Immermannstraße, dann findest du halt auf Google die Immermannstraße in Düsseldorf und nicht in Hintertupfingen und auch nicht in Königswusterhausen.
Oder Immermann Immobilien, 3 km weiter.
Oder in Berlin. Ich habe auch das Gefühl, egal wo du bist, wenn du deine Heimatadresse in Berlin hast, dass das dann auch eine Gewichtung hat. Ich finde die Suche und sich auch ziemlich schlecht. Trotzdem funktioniert alles andere gut genug, dass ich es trotzdem benutze. Aber ich habe schon oft diesen Moment gehabt, wo ich dachte, alter, wie vollständig, wie fully qualified muss jetzt die Adresse da stehen, damit du sie findest? Ich habe auch schon oft geflucht, dass diese Suche eigentlich keine Funktion hat. Wenn du nicht eh genau weißt, die Postleitzahl, die Hausnummer, das Staat, das Land, dann findet das oft die Sachen nicht. Das ist natürlich ganz im Gegensatz zu anderen Location-Suchen. Ich finde ja übrigens, wo wir gerade beim Map sind, ich habe in meinem Kurs an der UDK immer die Aufgabe zum Weltwissen beizutragen, wo die beliebtesten Optionen von meiner Seite Wikipedia oder Open Street Map sind. Letztens habe ich mal wieder Open Street Map angebraucht. Jedes Jahr oder jedes Semester, wenn ich diesen Kurs mache, tut sich da auch immer wieder was am Interface. Mittlerweile ist auch die Open Street Map Webseite ziemlich schick geworden. Ich weiß ja nicht, wenn ihr das letzte Mal da drauf gebraust seid, aber...
Gefühlt vor sieben Jahren, als ich auch das letzte Mal noch Dinge bei Open Street Map hingetragen habe.
Ich finde, die machen halt immer so kleine User Interface Verbesserungen. Da ich diesen Kurs seit acht fucking Jahren mache, habe ich schon viel von Open Street Map im Laufe der Zeit gesehen. Und mir fallen diese kleinen Änderungen immer wieder auf. Ich finde das sehr sympathisch. Und ich finde es auch toll, dass ich meine Studenten ab und zu immer noch dazu bewegen kann, Informationen da reinzukippen.
Also, naja, was konkret findest du da jetzt so neu?
Die haben mal die UI überarbeitet.
Genau, die UI ist halt irgendwie insgesamt besser klickbar. Also es war alles schon mal viel schlimmer und langsamer und hässlicher.
Wenn du das Fenster ein bisschen größer hast, siehst du auch, dass unter der Suche noch ein Hinweis ist.
Dass unter der Suche ein Hinweis ist?
Ja, wenn das Fenster größer ist, hast du unter dieser Suche noch irgendwie so einen... Willkommen bei OpenStreetMap.
Was ist denn denn eine andere OpenStreetMap?
Org.
Org, nicht DE.
Aber die steht dir gar nicht da.
Irgendwie hatte ich auch den Eindruck, dass das bei mir letztens noch schicker aussah als bei dir gerade. Aber das kann ja nur eine Illusion sein.
Ja, es gibt hier verschiedene Karten für Auswahl.
Nee, nee, nee, auch... Wie gesagt, es sind halt so Details vor allen Dingen. Also wie gesagt, wahrscheinlich kann man das jetzt nicht im Webarchive nachgucken, wie OpenStreetMap früher aussah. Aber ich finde schon, dass es im... Und die haben ja auch jetzt diese Routing-Option drin, die funktioniert jetzt mittlerweile auch so, dass man fast davon sprechen könnte, dass es funktioniert, so wie man das erwartet. Und auch diese Layers, wo du sozusagen dann die Informationen dann klicken kannst, war früher auch immer totaler Krampf, irgendwie die Tags da so ein bisschen zu durchbrausen. Und das ist alles so im Detail ein bisschen schicker geworden. Ich finde das gut. Ja, das stimmt. Zum Beispiel, wenn du jetzt hier bei... Wo war denn das? Ist ja auf Deutsch jetzt bei dir schon wieder. War das bei... Map Data und Map Notes heißt das bei mir, genau. Und wie heißt das bei dir? Wenn du da auf die Layers klickst? Hinweise und Fehlermeldungen, Kartendaten, genau. Dann kriegst du ja diesen... Das dauert jetzt einen Moment, weil du relativ... Also du hast jetzt gerade noch viel Infos auf dem Schirm. Das dauert immer so einen kleinen Moment. Der Spinning Beachball of Death kommt auch kurz zum Vorschein. Und jetzt kannst du halt alles, was da sozusagen getaggt und geoutlined ist, anklicken. Und dann kriegst du in der Sidebar, die irgendwo dann erscheinen müsste, sozusagen alles, was halt dazu steht. Und es gab es alles schon früher und so. Aber ich finde, mittlerweile ist es halt auch für Leute, die sich jetzt noch nicht so eingehend damit beschäftigt haben, so ein bisschen erfahrbarer und schicker gemacht. Wie gesagt, im Detail.
Ich begrüße das.
Und schön langsam vor allem.
Na ja, das mit den Kartendaten ist halt, je nachdem, wie weit du rausgezoomt hast, ist halt auch echt einfach viel Shit, der da reinfließt.
Kein Grund, unresponsive zu werden.
Ja, das ist die Erwartungshaltung natürlich. Ich finde es auch immer wieder schön, weil die meisten Studenten, die haben zwar ohne, dass sie es wissen, schon mal Open-Street-Map-Daten verwendet, so mit der einen oder anderen Offline-Map oder was auch immer. Aber immer wenn ich denen so sage, und jetzt zeige ich euch ein tolles Projekt, das ähnlich ist wie, also vom Konzept her wie Wikipedia, wir machen jetzt das mit Karten, und zeige denen einfach so die Informationstiefe, die da drin ist, dann sind die auch regelmäßig so geflasht. Da steht drin, wie viel Strom auf der S-Bahn-Schiene ist und wie schnell man da fahren kann auf der Schiene und wie die Spurweite ist und wie... Also wirklich, da steht ja einfach jedes Detail drin. Du kannst ja auch auf die Umspannwerke von den Überlandleitungen gehen und dann siehst du auf jeder einzelnen Spule, was der Transformator da eigentlich umwandelt und wie viel Volt da durchgehen. Und sehr einfach ohne Ende Info.
Mal gucken, ob die Ladestationen...
Ja, geil!
Bei mir ist nicht drin.
Ja, geil, dann habt ihr doch gleich einen Open-Street-Map-Auftrag. Das ist doch geil.
Aber stimmt doch, wie viel Power da rauskommt und welche Stecker da sind.
Na, erstmal muss die überhaupt zu sehen sein.
Was ist das denn?
Ist das nicht die, die da ein Stück weiter oben drüber ist?
Nein, das ist die Straße. Hier sind wir Charging bei den Layers. Aber wo steht denn da jetzt was dazu?
Ja, da links steht halt nur der Socketype. Da müsstest du dann sozusagen mal selber ein paar Tags hinzufügen. Aber das ist auf jeden Fall eine super Anwendung für Open-Street-Map.
Du kannst erst mal den Bezirksnamen korrigieren. Da ist mich falsch.
Ja, also das ist auch das Schöne an Open-Street-Map. Da kann man immer noch viel verbessern.
Aber wo stand denn diese Information gerade drin mit dem Prenzlauer?
Der ganze Prenzlauerberg falsch.
Das könnte ich mir schon mal vorstellen.
Schön finde ich den Straßenbaum.
Lade-Station für Elektroautos, Plug-in-Hybride, Objekt ändern, Kapazität.
Hier alle Eigenschaften.
Das sind die, die es schon gibt. Aber du kannst ja plus drücken, also du kannst jetzt weitere Tags hinzuaddieren. Also ich finde halt, dieses ganze Interface ist deutlich besser klickbar. Das war früher schon deutlich schlimmer, also oder schwieriger da überhaupt mal zu verstehen, wie man da Sachen hintaggt, auch wenn das immer noch verbesserungswürdig ist.
Meinst du mit Kapazität?
Gibt es einen Wiki-Link?
Kapazität? Wahrscheinlich der Ladestrom, oder?
Das ist aber nicht die Kapazität.
Oder wie viel?
Die Kapazität, eine Einrichtung anzugeben.
Für Menschen mit Behinderung, für Frauen, für Eltern mit Kindern.
Ah, Anzahl der Parkplätze, die zur Verfügung stehen. Also wahrscheinlich wie viele Autos man da gleichzeitig laden kann.
Wahrscheinlich dann zwei.
Und jetzt?
Also wenn ich jetzt hier bearbeite, eine Sache. Ach Gottchen, da muss ich erstmal mich einloggen.
Ich hab's gemacht, ich hab einen Beitrag.
Hast du jetzt Wenzlauer Berg gefixt? Nee, das noch nicht, das müssen wir gleich auch noch finden.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wo diese Information steht.
Also, Freak Show 201, live Open Street Map-Editierung. Und jetzt können die Leute in der History schnell nachgucken, in welcher Straße Tim wohnt.
Das können sie auch auf meiner Webseite nachschauen.
Weiß ich doch.
Ja, hier steht jetzt aber nichts mehr mit Prinz Lauer Berg. Irgendwas hab ich falsch gemacht.
Ich leg noch mal auf die Ladestation einmal.
Ich glaub, du warst halt vorher nicht im Bearbeiten-Modus und jetzt bist du gerade im Bearbeiten-Modus.
Genau, aber...
Wie ich war nicht im Bearbeiten-Modus.
Als Prinz Lauer Berg mit Esther stand, war das dieser Ansicht-Modus oder Information über das...
So, jetzt hab ich das doch hier... Also da ist so ein... Änderungskommentar...
Ladestation für Elektronik...
Ja, was soll ich denn da zu sagen? Kapazität hinzugefügt, aber das erlebt sich doch von alleine. Aber soll ich dir was sagen, was passieren wird als nächstes? Na, meine Änderung wird wahrscheinlich als relevant angesehen und dann irgendwie wieder gelöscht.
Nee, das ist ja nicht die Wikipedia.
Das macht einen so wahnsinnig, diese Wikipedia.
Also, das fand ich ja auch das Schöne an Open Street, weilst du mir das, glaube ich, oder irgendjemand, weiß nicht, ob du oder Mar oder irgendwie oder vielleicht hast du das auch im Kurs mal gewinnt, dass das Motto halt ja mal früher MAP THE PLANET war. Und da kannst du ja reintaggen, was du willst, prinzipiell. Nur, das, was ich ja als Wikipedia-Modell auch bevorzugen würde, ich als tendenzieller Inkludist wäre, dass du zwar alles reinschreibst, aber die Encyclopädie-Fanatiker halt die Artikel relevant markieren für Encyclopedien. Und wenn du den Encyclopädie-View haben willst, dann sagst du halt so, ich geh jetzt auf encyclopedia.wikipedia.org, dann kriegst du halt nur alle Artikel, die von den Admins als relevant geblässt wurden. Aber wenn du in die Treschopedia oder die Gartenwichtelpedia gehst, dann kriegst du halt auch alle anderen Artikel. Das ist ja so ein bisschen das Open-Street-Map-Prinzip, weil du kannst ja alles Mögliche taggen, und Leute machen ja auch allen möglichen Scheiß mit diesem Open-Street-Map. Nur wenn du auf openstreetmap.org gehst, dann kriegst du halt ein Rendering von allem dem, was für den Stadtplan relevant ist. Und wenn du auf die Wheelmap gehst, kriegst du halt alles, was für Rollstuhlfahrer relevant ist. Und wenn du auf die Kräutermap gehst, dann kriegst du halt ein View für alles, was für Pflanzenliebhaber wichtig ist und CycleMap etc. Und das wäre eigentlich für die Wikipedia, finde ich das auch, genauso cool.
Jetzt ist mir klar geworden, warum da Prenzlauer Berg drin stand. Hast du es gesehen, warum es jetzt nicht mehr drin stand, Tim? Der Hinweis, der da kam, ist, das letzte Kommentar, was du eingibst, was du geändert hast.
War die letzte Änderung, das Änderungskommentar.
Das hat überhaupt so in dem Sinne nichts damit zu tun, dass die in Prenzleberg steht.
Das Lustige ist, dass er dir hier Änderungskommentare vorschlägt. Und da stehen halt irgendwelche Uraltänderungen von mir drin, wo ich in Italien was geändert habe und wo ich in Jamaika was geändert habe.
Das ist wahrscheinlich davon ausgeht, dass du irgendwie so ein Nerd bist, der einfach bestimmte Änderungen immer wieder macht.
Eventuell, ja.
Powertagger.
So.
Elektro-Sound-Position angepasst.
Ich habe mich jetzt hier erfolgreich High Sierra installiert und habe jetzt hier Native-APFS-Booting vom Mac Pro.
So, wie komme ich jetzt aus diesem Bearbeiten wieder raus?
Lass uns mal weiter schreiten.
Browser schließen, Neustart, Cookie löschen.
Lass uns mal hier irgendwie zu Kram kommen. Also, ihr habt sicherlich auch diese komischen AR-Kit-Demos gesehen, die so in den letzten Wochen durch Twitter standen, wo jetzt alle irgendwie iOS 11 genommen haben und dann so My First AR-Application gemacht haben, die ja immer im Prinzip dasselbe ist. Du schaltest die Kamera an, dann sagt dir irgendwie das OS, hier ist die Geometrie und dann kannst du da so ein 3D-Element drauf machen. Da ist einerseits oder andererseits halt so Erkennung der Kamera, also sozusagen was ist da zu sehen und so. Halt so AR-Kram, mit diesem Machine Learning, was sie ja auf der WWDC vorgestellt haben. Und so weit ist das auch alles ganz gut. Und jetzt ist halt diese Beta raus. Und jetzt macht halt so jeder irgendwie solche Apps. Und das Netz ist irgendwie voll davon mit, was das jetzt wieder für eine geile Eingaberevolution ist. Und das ist ja überhaupt nicht der totale Knaller.
Zeig mal eine. Ich habe noch nicht eine einzige gesehen, offensichtlich.
Ich kann dir eine zeigen, aber die ist nicht mit AR-Kit. Die ist von Pavel.
Ja, das ist genau das gleiche.
Pavel-Kit.
Es gibt hier irgendwie so einen, wie heißt der nochmal hier? Dieser AR-Kit-Demos oder wie heißt der genau? Das ist so ein Twitter-Account, der irgendwie solche Sachen macht. Und im Wesentlichen ist es immer wieder dasselbe.
Er blendet halt irgendwas irgendwo ein, ne?
Leute blenden halt irgendwas irgendwo ein. Dann gibt es halt so ein paar Sachen, die sind schon so ein bisschen pfiffiger. Zum Beispiel, ich glaube das Erste, was so ein bisschen Aufmerksamkeit erzeugt ist, du nimmst in deiner Umgebung ein Maßband, so ein Zentimeter Maßband, legst es irgendwo hin auf den Tisch, so und dann filmst du diese Szene mit deiner AR App. Die erkennt halt das Maßband als solches und erkennt halt auch die Skala auf dem Maßband und damit kalibrierst du quasi alle Größen in deiner Kamera.
Und die weiß, ob das Zentimeter oder Zoll sind?
Wer hat das, Kit?
Das kannst du halt in deine App irgendwie rein programmieren. Keine Ahnung, darum geht es ja jetzt auch erstmal gar nicht. Sondern es geht ja darum, dass du auf einmal quasi eine Bemassung vornehmen kannst. Weil es heißt ja auch, wenn du das quasi so kalibriert hast, dann kannst du halt auf deine Schrankwand zeigen, wo du schon immer mal wissen wolltest, wie groß dieser innere Bereich ist. Und da halt das AR Kit auch alle Kanten findet und alle Objekte findet und weiß, wo Dinge anfangen und aufhören, kannst du halt automatisch dann auch, und weil es auch die dreidimensionale Position im Raum relativ zu allen anderen Positionen im Raum hat, kannst du quasi eine automatische Bemassung machen. Zeig es halt irgendwo hin, dann sagt dir, die Wand ist so und so hoch, so und so breit. Was zum Beispiel für Raumvermessung mal ein echtes Feature wäre. Also derzeit gibt es ja nur so Apps, da musst du deine Kamera immer so im Kreis halten, so Panorama Modus, musst immer irgendwelche Punkte setzen und da dann das irgendwie mehr oder weniger alles manuell rein machen. Und ich wäre schon ganz froh mit einer App, die tatsächlich so diese Einrichtungsgeschichte machen kann. Weil ich halte immer so dieses, ich habe einen Raum, was kann ich da reinbauen? Wie viel Platz ist da? Wie breit ist eigentlich diese Wand? Wie groß ist dieser Abstand von da nach da? Wie hoch ist der ganze Scheiß? Wie hoch darf das Regal sein? Das sind alles so Fragen.
Drang zur Gestaltung.
Bist du stundenlang irgendwie am Machen.
Wie war das jetzt nochmal mit dem Maskband? Was musst du machen dafür? War das ein Wunsch oder ist das Realität?
Das ist so eine App, die hier so gezeigt wurde. Ich weiß gerade nicht, warum dieses blöde Twitter hier nicht weiter scrollt.
Jetzt wo Kalender scrollen, dann hört Twitter auf zu scrollen. Nein, es ist wirklich... Irgendwas geht immer kaputt.
Irgendwie hat der hier wieder die Hälfte gelöscht oder was? Warte mal, ich suche einfach mal nach... ARKit, Demo, Rula, da findest du das bestimmt sofort. Schöner Musik, ist das nicht schön?
Das sind jetzt aber Zoll, oder?
Egal, was es ist. Du quantifizierst halt deine Umgebung. Sieht ja noch nicht so mega akkurat aus, aber du kannst quasi automatisch kalibriert auf ein real existierendes Ding dein eigenes Maßband machen. So und jetzt vermisst er halt irgendwelche Schränke, Bilder an der Wand.
Aber wie soll das funktionieren?
Wie das funktionieren soll? Mit AR Kit. Das ist ja genau das, was die AR Kit macht.
Hat er da jetzt unten ein Maßband draufliegen? Oder ist das jetzt auch schon in einem Virtual gezeichnet?
Das gewesen.
Nee, das war glaube ich ein draufgelegtes.
Aber wo... Das würde ich erstmal in echt sehen.
Na das ist ja hier in echt.
Na ja, das ist ein Video.
Ja, aber gut, mir ging es ja jetzt nicht darum, diese My First AR Kit Apps zu preisen, sondern die eigentliche Frage, die dahintersteht ist, wir hatten ja hier auch vor ein paar Sendungen immer wieder diese Diskussion mit, was ist denn jetzt das neue User Interface? Und da gibt es halt so drei Fraktionen, würde ich sagen. Die einen sind, nichts wird sich ändern, andere sind, alles ist Cyber, 3D, VR, Brille, ja, weil geil.
Cyber, Cyber!
Und wir hatten ja hier Ralf, der das auch kräftig vertreten hat.
Oh, nur so ein bisschen.
Ja, schönen Gruß an Ralf, der sicherlich gerade zuhört. Hallo Ralf. Und ich habe nicht sehr viel mehr gemacht, als da meine fortwährende Skepsis angemeldet, weil wie gesagt, das VR-Versprechen höre ich schon seit 30 Jahren, aber ich sehe halt immer noch nicht, dass alle Leute irgendwie sich diese Brillen aufsetzen. Jetzt kommt halt Apple dazwischen mit dieser AR-Nummer und sagt halt, ja okay, also Reality schon, aber eigentlich interessant ist halt unsere Reality und wir bauen halt jetzt ein System, was in der Lage ist, in Echtzeit ein möglichst umfassendes Verständnis dieser Umgebung, dieser Realität, an eine Software zu liefern, damit die dann damit machen kann, was sie möchte.
Das war schon Left Field irgendwie, also das kam sehr überraschend fand ich, weil so in der Art und Weise war das jetzt im Halbcycle nicht eingepreist, fand ich, was Apple jetzt da macht. So nach der Art, wir bauen euch mal die Umgebungserkennung, damit ihr dann da 3D-Objekte reinplacken könnt. Also hatte ich nicht auf dem Schirm, dass das jemand anders so machen würde.
Ja, die haben ja schon länger gesagt, dass sie AR für sehr wichtig halten. Das hat Tim Cook schon vor einem Jahr gesagt.
Hab ich mitgekriegt.
Ja, doch klar. Hier bei dieser, wie heißt das? Diese All Things Die oder wie heißt die Konferenz? Jetzt Die Konferenz, keine Ahnung. Oder Recode, irgendwie.
Nee, All Things Die wahrscheinlich.
Ja, das heißt aber jetzt glaube ich Recode.
Mit diesem Ziegenbart-Typen da.
Wolf Mosberg.
Genau, das heißt jetzt Recode.
Das ist auch ein rentegegangener Typ.
Auch noch. Auf jeden Fall gibt es Interviews mit ihm, wo er das gesagt hat.
Wortwörtlich.
Was für mich jetzt, sagen wir mal, dieses Release jetzt nicht so überraschend hat wirken lassen, überraschend fand ich nur ihre doch relativ konsequente Umsetzung. Dass sie halt sagen, naja, Machine Learning und künstliche Intelligenz, das ist jetzt da und wir bauen halt mal wieder die Infrastruktur, um das eben auch für Anwendungsentwickler wirklich sinnvoll nutzbar zu machen. Weil selbstverständlich willst du dich nicht mit diesen ganzen KI Trainings Algorithmen rumschlagen, sondern willst halt irgendwie fertige Trainings Files nehmen von irgendjemand, den du vielleicht beauftragst, oder wenn du Bock hast, machst du es halt auch selber. Du willst dich halt darauf konzentrieren, dass deine App die richtigen Hooks hat, um in dieser Umgebung irgendwie das Richtige tun kann. Es gibt das Gerücht, dass IKEA da jetzt auch irgendwie seinen Heimplaner damit machen kann und das ist in der Tat eine ganz interessante Option, finde ich, weil wenn du jetzt wirklich in deiner leeren Küche stehst, oder vielleicht auch in deiner vollen und so die App kann halt einerseits alles vermessen, andererseits kannst du aber dann auch direkt im Kamerabild deiner Küche eine neue Küche reinmalen, die du so mit so einem Fenster in die neue Realität anschauen kannst, da kann ich mir durchaus vorstellen, dass das ganz gut einschlagen könnte. Das hätte vielleicht sogar auch so Killer App anscheinend. Die Frage ist nur, war es das dann schon oder gibt es dann noch mehr? Also können wir uns vorstellen, dass dieses aus der Realität heraus sein Primärsetting zu nehmen für mehr als nur Spieler irgendwie eine Anwendung ist, die man wirklich haben will?
Naja, weiß ich nicht, habe ich irgendwann ja schon mal gesagt, so interaktive iFixit, ich nehme mein Gerät auseinander, Anleitungen. Als ich meine SSD, also ich habe irgendwann eine SSD in Mac Mini eingebaut. Das ist so ein 2012er Modell, da kann man noch zwei 2,5 Zoll Drives reinbauen. Was mir nicht so ganz klar war, ist, man muss das Teil komplett auseinandernehmen, wirklich komplett, bis man das leere Alugehäuse hat. Und dann kann man anfangen, das Teil da reinzuschrauben, und dann muss man alles wieder zusammenbauen. Und an der Stelle wäre so ein VR-geführte Anleitung, was wohin gehört und vor allen Dingen in welche Richtung man es drehen muss, bevor man es in die doch sehr kleine Lücke, wo es reinsteckt, das wäre schon angenehm gewesen. Also ich habe es auch so hingekriegt, das waren nur nicht die fünf Minuten, die ich dachte, sondern eher eine dreiviertel Stunde. Aber ja.
Was es ja schon früher gab, ich weiß nicht mehr genau, wie die App hieß, aber die gab es schon vor einigen Jahren. Ich weiß nicht, ob die überhaupt gut funktioniert hat. Das war ja schon so eine App, wo du die Kamera nimmst und dann die auf irgendein Schild hältst, wo was drauf steht. Bitte?
World Lens oder World Lens oder World Lens.
World Lens?
So hieß die, glaube ich.
Na ja, Google Translate macht das ja auch.
Genau, die haben die nicht so gekauft oder zumindest die Leute abgebaut.
Google Translate macht das auch schon so live aufs Bild dann drauf oder was.
Wenn du die Google Translate App hast, schon, ja.
Gab es nicht auch mal irgendwas, was die Wikipedia mit integriert hatte?
Na ja, auf jeden Fall rechts das war das Iconer, World Lens und so und weiß nicht, ob das gekauft wurde oder Google das dann einfach selber gemacht hat, kurzerhand.
Na gut, also so eine Anwendung. Die Frage ist nur, ist das jetzt ein großes Ding oder nicht?
Ja, also von mir aus könnte das auch auf dem Foto passieren. Also ich muss es jetzt nicht unbedingt die ganze Zeit live haben, aber das Schild ist ja statisch. Also es muss jetzt nicht so.
Ja gut, aber wenn du so eine große Wand hast, wo alles voll mit irgendwelchen hieroglyphischen und japanischen Schriftzeichen ist, dann fängst du ja nicht an, jedes einzelne Ding zu fotografieren. Ja, sondern du willst ja das ja sozusagen auch.
Ja, das funktioniert gut. Apple erworben hat Metaio, ein vermehrt Realitätsstaat, die gestartet Weg zurück 2003, als ein Ableger von einem Projekt bei Volkswagen.
War das jetzt gerade?
Das war diese Übersicht im Slack von Apple acquires augmented reality company mit. Aber immerhin, er macht's on the fly. Ich weiß nicht, es gab früher schon Anwendungen, wo so ein Airbus auch mal im Programm hatte, dass sie Leute, die irgendwelche Reparatur und Maintenance an Flugzeugen gemacht haben, auch so ein AR Zeug an die Hand gegeben haben, wo halt dann eingezeichnet ist, die Schraube muss jetzt da hin und das musst du jetzt da und so weiter, damit du es wieder findest. Und ich glaube, da sind die Möglichkeiten sehr, sehr groß. Also gerade, wenn du so, weiß ich nicht, Mechaniker, die von der Materie nicht so viel Ahnung haben, aber mit dem Schraubenzieher umgehen können, halt relativ schnell ranführen willst, ein Gerät zu reparieren, was sie noch nie gesehen haben, dann bist du, glaube ich...
Ich weiß gar nicht, mit wem ich darüber, oder wer mir das erzählt hat, dass es auch irgendwelche Hersteller von großen Maschinen machen, also extrem häufig, dass die sagen, hier Schulungsvideos oder so sind halt irgendwie nicht mehr so geil für große Maschinen, sondern die nehmen so eine AR-Sachen, um die Reparaturen an irgendwelchen, sich großen Kränen irgendwie vorzunehmen. Aber daran kann ich mich nur ganz dunkel erinnern.
Ist nicht auch so, dass die AR-Community dieses neue File-Format für diese Trainingsdaten voll toll findet?
Keine Ahnung, also ich meine, wenn so ein Amazon-Lager mit den sich selbst bewegenden Regalen ausfällt, dann ist es sowieso vorbei. Ja, aber dann könntest du immerhin noch mit deinem AR irgendwie durch die Halle, wo alle Roboter die Geräte gemacht haben, laufen und das Zeug so aus dem Regal holen.
Weil irgendwie...
Ich lasse dich live übersetzen. Deinen Gesichtsausdruck.
Grumpy old guy.
Mr. Charming, wie er leibt und liebt.
Hier gibt's noch leckere Schokolade.
Ich würde was ausprobieren. Ich werde es nicht veröffentlichen natürlich.
Ich finde sie relativ unattraktiv oder uninteressant. Ich schaff's auch alleine noch, so einen Zollschock in die Hand zu nehmen und alles auszupassen.
Ja, wenn man da rankommt.
So sieht's aus.
Ja, ja, ja schon, aber ich finde, das ist irgendwie...
Außerdem ist es jetzt die Spielphase. Jetzt ist natürlich wieder jeder Honk und sein Bruder, die spielen jetzt mit AR rum. Das wird sich demnächst alles ein bisschen ausfiltern und dann kommen die coolen Sachen. Also es ist doch gut, die sollen wir alle testen.
Eigentlich ist es geil, dass jeder Honk und sein Bruder wieder so schön sagt, damit jetzt spielen kann, weil da kommen dann die coolen Ideen.
Und die Qualität kommt am Ende übrig sein. Und das ist auch gut so. Und dann kommen auch frische Ideen, weil halt...
Ist ja ein bisschen wie ein Puppenpuppen. Ja, das ist schon enorm, man darf sie nicht so sehr an diesem Video festhalten. Das ist ja im Prinzip so eine Art Realitäts-Livestreaming, was da jetzt irgendwie angeschaltet wird. Du blickst die ganze Zeit auf das, was sich vor deiner Nase da quasi abspielt und das wird noch mal ganz pfiffig werden. Na gut, damit wir die Kleinigkeiten vielleicht noch abgearbeitet haben, gleich noch mal ein schönes größeres Thema aufgreifen. Aber ich habe noch mal so ein Tipp und zwar To Do Apps. Das ist ja auch so ein Ding. Ich weiß nicht, wer von euch die benutzt.
Gelegentlich benutze ich Wunderliste.
Buy me a pie, nur zum einkaufen.
Eine Mischung aus doch Papier, weil irgendwie besser und Org-Mode für den Emax.
Das ist eigentlich die coole Antwort.
Alles, was ich mir nicht merken kann, ist nicht wichtig.
Das sind die C-Punkt-Attitüde.
Ich weiß, da gehen manchmal Sachen unter, die doch wichtig waren.
Doch, das passiert bei mir oft. Ich habe keine Ahnung, wie viele Phasen ich schon gehabt habe, wo ich jetzt mit To Do Lösungen sowieso losgehe. Ich bin dann immer vollkommen versumpft in diesen ganzen Systemen, die dann entweder nicht accessible genug waren oder nicht so richtig meine Denkstruktur abgebildet haben, die irgendwie zu kompliziert waren, die einfach das Falsche priorisiert haben und so weiter. Und auch diese ganzen webbasierten Sachen. Mit Wunderlist habe ich auch nur so ein bisschen rumgespielt, aber bin ich auch nicht weit gekommen.
Das Ding, was mich dabei überzeugt, im Vergleich zu den meisten anderen Lösungen, ist, dass wir das mit dem Syncing hinbekommen haben. Das synkt einfach.
Das ist natürlich die absolute Voraussetzung. Also Synken muss laufen.
Deswegen bei mir Pi. Der synkt auch sehr schön. Aber es ist, wie gesagt, nur eine Einkaufsliste. Insofern ist es nicht so interessant, als To Do-Liste eher nicht so zu gebrauchen.
Genau, also man braucht mal was, was To Do richtig kann. Was irgendwie einerseits genug Features hat, andererseits aber auch so stripped down genug ist. Ich hatte ganz gute Erfahrungen gesammelt mit Things. Das habe ich schon vor längerer Zeit mal gekauft. Dann habe ich es mal eine ganze Weile lang benutzt. Danach war es mir dann auch irgendwann wieder mal zu kompliziert. Das war dann auch noch so diese Phase, wo sie selber extrem mit dieser Syncherei gekämpft haben. Das ist ja irgendwie auch so eine Entwicklungsphase der gesamten Softwarebranche. Und mittlerweile haben sie einerseits das mit dem Synchern auch extrem stabil hinbekommen, andererseits haben sie jetzt gerade eine neue Version von ihrem SYNCHS gemacht. Und da haben sie mal wieder was gemacht, was ich immer sehr schön finde. Sie haben noch mal über alles nachgedacht und sie haben alles irgendwie neu ausgelegt und neu strukturiert und auch ihr ganzes User Interface neu gemacht. Und ich muss sagen, ich bin sehr angetan von dem neuen SYNCHS. Wer also da vielleicht ohnehin schon drin steckt da in einem Ökosystem und über ein Upgrade nachdenkt, kann ich eigentlich nur empfehlen, es wird extrem übersichtlich und extrem logisch. Und gerade als wir so Appleheads genau das Richtige war...
49 Euro für den Mac.
Na ja, das war schon immer nicht ganz niedrigpreisig. Also ich hab's vor Jahren mal benutzt, aber es hat mich dann letzten Endes nicht so überzeugt. Aber gut. Also sie haben sich ja sehr stark an dieses Getting Things Done Modell damals zumindest orientiert. Und das muss man halt auch wollen. Also...
Ich weiß nicht von Getting Things Done, hab ich jetzt hier nicht so viel...
Na ja, doch man sieht es ist immer noch relativ stark. Getting Things Done. Ich meine, das Ding heißt ja Things. Wegen Getting Things Done. Dazu musste das Getting Things Done Buch gelesen haben, um zu wissen, warum. Das ist so eine Philosophie, das wie organisiere ich mich.
Ich hatte mir das schon mal auf meine Liste geschrieben.
Der alte Witz kommt doch noch zum Vorschein. Also ich finde es auch immer wieder faszinierend, weil ja so gerade wenn man sich so beim Programmieren so ein bisschen umschaut, dann ist ja so eine To Do List immer so eins der beliebten Tutorials. Also bei Rails war es am Anfang ein Blog, aber dann später gab es auch ganz viele To Do Listen und auch in der JavaScript-Framework-Welt waren To Do Listen dann ganz weit vorne. Und ich finde es immer wieder faszinierend, wie viele Gedanken man sich so zu To Do Listen machen kann.
Das Wunderlist ist auch nur ein aus der Kontrolle geratenes JavaScript-Framework.
Also am Ende des Tages ist ja das Konzept sehr ähnlich. Es gibt halt Dinge, die erledigt werden müssen, die man auf einer Liste schreibt und dann abhakt, wenn man sie getan hat und dann wird die Liste hoffentlich weniger. Man fühlt sich besser. Und dieses Konzept kann man halt so mannigfaltig ausspielen. Ich bin immer wieder begeistert von der ganzen Kreativität und dem Hirnschmalz, der investiert wird, um dieses wirklich wahnsinnig wichtige Weltproblem zu lösen.
Also ich mache das immer noch mit Zetteln.
Ich habe da auch echt sehr viel Zeit investiert, bevor ich... Also Org Mode war so das erste, wo ich sage, es ist schön und es ist gut. Also ich habe am Anfang Workflowy gesehen. Ja, ich würde am besten von Workflowy anfangen, weil wahrscheinlich viele diesen Outliner Workflowy kennen. Den habe ich so gesehen und fand das irgendwie nicht schlecht. Fand es aber irgendwie auch doch schlecht. So von der Bedienung, von der, von der, was man damit machen kann. Und Org Mode ist ein Modul, was zum Emacs gehört.
Aber sind das auch in die Cloud?
Das basiert auf Textfiles. Das heißt, du kannst natürlich dir deine To Do Listen abspeichern, irgendwo hinlegen und die dann sünden. Habe ich aber jetzt nicht unbedingt gemacht, weil ich zum Beispiel auch nicht... Mit Git kannst du das.
Aber auf deinem Telefon hast du ja kein Emacs.
Richtig, aber es ist ein Textfile. Das heißt, jeder dumme Editor kann das Ding öffnen und sieht das.
Zeig doch mal einen Screenshot von diesem Org Mode. Ich habe Emacs das letzte Mal vor 12 Jahren aktiv benutzt, glaube ich. Und da waren To Do Listen nicht meine Kernanwendung. Deswegen ist dieser Org Mode schon bestimmt an mir vorbei gegangen.
Aber naja, das ist halt so Text.
Lass mich kurz meinen Ordner finden.
Na ja, der Org Mode muss ja auch irgendwas können. Oh, es gibt ein Reference Manual.
Kannst du noch mal ganz nach oben scrollen vielleicht am besten? So sieht das Teil aus, so Plain Text kannst du es irgendwie...
Du musst das beschreiben für unsere Hörer.
Sieht aus wie ein Git Log.
Ja, eigentlich kann man es vielleicht mit Markdown am ehesten vergleichen. Du hast so ein paar Sterne, die du zum Listen machen benutzen kannst. Und die haben als einfache To Do Liste, also wo es dann wirklich um die To Do Liste geht, sind die eckigen Klammern. Also eckige Klammer auf, eckige Klammer zu. Wenn die leer ist, ist es eine noch nicht abgearbeitete To Do. Und wenn du eine X reinsetzt, dann ist es abgearbeitet. Das wäre so das einfachste für eine reine To Do Liste. Was das halt auch kann, ist Zeit tracken in der Tat. Das habe ich aber nie wirklich benutzt. Du kannst dir damit komplette Kalender bauen, irgendwie mit diesem Org-Mode. Also ich habe das wirklich auf einfachster Ebene gesetzt. Ich will eigentlich nur eine To Do Liste haben, vielleicht eine verschachtelte Liste mit. Ich habe irgendwie in einem Projekt Backend, Frontend und in meinem Frontend irgendwie CSS und was weiß ich, eine Template-Geschichte. Ich habe mir das irgendwie schon so zurechtgeschachtelt und danach eigentlich erst die eigentlichen To Do's reingemacht.
Zwei Fragen. Folgefragen. Die einfache ist, wenn du Emacs auf dem neuen MacBook Pro benutzt, hast du dann die Meta-Taste auf der Touchbar.
Was hast du denn punkten zurückgebringt? Ich habe wieder Papier.
Ja, das wäre tatsächlich mal eine cooles Feature von der Touchbar, dass du die ganzen Special Keykombos auf der... Egal. Das war natürlich nur eine Spaßfrage. Die zweite Frage ist eigentlich, also Workflowy erscheint mir jetzt ja quasi erstmal, also was ist an diesem Textmode besser als in Workflowy?
Dass du es mischen kannst. In Workflowy hast du ja so diesen reinen Outliner und kannst aus dem nicht ausbrechen. Also du kannst jetzt nicht irgendwie einen Textblock dazwischen setzen. Das kannst du da. Also es ist wirklich sehr ähnlich zum Markdown von der Struktur her.
Aber was für zusätzliche Features bietet dieser Org-Mode, außer dass du da so Mark abschreiben kannst, also trackt der dann, wie viele Tasks noch offen sind?
Das kannst du auch machen. Genau, du kannst ihnen sagen, ich müsste gucken, wie die Syntax war, aber du kannst halt auch sagen, hier, das ist eben diese Gruppe von Tasks, die ich dir zu tun habe. Und dann zählt dir, du hast so und so viel von so und so viel schon erledigt. Wenn du halt das Zeit-Tracken mit einschaltest, dann kannst du sagen, okay, ich starte jetzt diesen Task, track mal, wie lange der braucht, und ich beende ihn dann halt auch wieder. Was natürlich, wenn du freelancest, eine nette Sache ist, wenn du das wirklich durchziehst. Du kannst auch innerhalb dieses Org-Modes dir Sachen wirklich schedulen. Das muss irgendwie fertig werden an dem und dem Tag. Dann kannst du dir einen Kalender anzeigen lassen. Also ich habe das Ding nicht bis zum Ende durch exerziert, aber ich fand das sehr, sehr cool.
Du bist nicht bis zum Ende Gegner vorgebrochen. Ich bin nicht. Ich benutze ja die Wunderlist vor allen Dingen, weil es lange Zeit eins der wenigen Tools war, was Syncing cool konnte. Wenn ich dann zu Hause saß, habe ich immer das ist alle, ich will das kochen, brauche ich mal das. Ich habe mir zu Hause eine Liste da. Und dann unterwegs mache ich meine Wunderlist auf und weiß, das sind die ganzen Items, die ich einkaufen muss. Das ist wirklich so klassischste To Do-Listen-Applikation, aber eben auch auf allen Geräten und so weiter. Und das würde mir dann ja da wiederum fehlen.
Aber Einkaufsliste Buy Me a Pie gibt nichts Besseres. Ja, Buy Me a Pie, Kaufe mir eine Pastete. Gibt es unter iOS und macOS und Syncht untereinander.
Und wie sieht das aus?
Du kannst verschiedene Listen anlegen. Supermarkt hier zum Beispiel. Und dann kannst du Produkte hinzufügen, die du kaufen willst.
Und kannst du die auch sehr befriedigend abchecken, weil das fand ich bei Wunderlist auch schön, dass diese ganzen Animationen erstellen und auch so erledigen. Das war sehr befriedigend.
Einmal schieben. Es ist da unten.
Du musst swipen, das ist ja schon relativ viel Arbeit.
Naja, du kannst es auch umschalten auf nur drauf testen, dann geht es auch weg. Aber gerade weil es so schön synkt und man halt so schnell mal nebenbei so, ah, da fehlt das, Phone raus, zack, Phone wieder weg. Und dann hast du die Liste halt relativ einfach immer aktuell. Du kannst im Supermarkt relativ einfach die auch abhaken. Deswegen für Einkaufslisten würde ich das nehmen, für alles andere ist es jetzt nicht so.
Wie gesagt, ich benutze das Wunderlist hauptsächlich auch für Einkaufslisten.
Und was ich sehr schön finde an BuyMeUp heißt, du kannst jedem Produkt eine Farbe zuweisen und dann sortiert er das nach Farben. Und ich mache das halt so, dass ich die Farben vergebe.
Obst und Gemüse.
Genau, für die Teile von Supermarkt. Grün ist frisches Zeug, jetzt dieses merkwürdige Braun ist halt so, was steht da jetzt? Maiswaffeln zum Beispiel. Das ist so dieses ganze Trockenfutter. Und dann gibt es irgendwie, ich glaube das Kühlregal ist bei mir hellblau, das Tiefkühlregal ist dunkelblau und sowas in der Art. Und dann ist es halt auch in Gruppen so sortiert, dass wenn du durch den Supermarkt durchgehst, du immer in der gleichen Gruppe bleibst.
To Do Item, To Do Liste organisieren.
Ich hab das grad in der Tat auf meinem Zettel auch so ein bisschen stehen, dass ich mich nicht dazwischen quatschen, du.
Doch, und dann ist der Korb schon fertig, man muss nur noch abholen und nach Hause gehen.
Dann zuckt der, ohne mit der Wimper zu zucken, fährt der einfach.
Sagt hier unser supergrätschen Huckel. Stimmt ja überhaupt gar nicht.
Ich hau erstmal für den Huckel noch ein Bild ins Slack.
Du hast ja den Begriff der Blutgrätsche überhaupt erst mal erfunden.
Jetzt lass mal die Letty ausreden.
Errgrätsche hast du gesagt, oder?
Aber ich sag's dir vorher an.
Ich würde deinen Blick einfach nochmal kurz ins Slack richten. Du kannst ja sogar, wie heißt das, Tags vergeben in diesen Listen.
Darf ich mal eine ganz böse Frage stellen? Gibt es das auch für ordentliche Editoren oder nur für Emacs?
Es gibt bestimmt einen Wim-Org-Mode.
Es kann gut sein, dass es da auch Plugins für gibt. Aber ich hab's halt mal eine Zeit lang genutzt. Und ich bin jetzt auch gerade so an diesem Suchen, wie ich mich so organisiere, wenn ich dann doch irgendwie nicht meinen ganzen Kram bei mir hab. Also ich finde halt Zettel und Stift immer noch sehr schön.
Ja, wenn ich eine gute Handschrift halte, dann könnte ich da mitarbeiten.
Oh, ich habe eine sehr gute.
Doch, ich kann meine eigene Schrift schon lesen. Aber irgendwie bin ich aus diesem Stiftpapier-Ding nie richtig mit warm geworden.
Dann hast du nicht den richtigen Stift wahrscheinlich gehabt bisher.
Ich kann dir so einen Lami-Füller empfehlen. Aber deswegen bin ich auch über Things nämlich auch schon drüber gestolpert, dass ich jetzt am überlegen bin, ob sowas nicht mit Synchronisation über allen Geräten irgendwie nice wäre. Hast du das über alle Geräte?
Ja, sonst würde es keinen Sinn machen.
Und hast du es dann über diese Cloud-Option von denen?
Ja.
Und das rockt total. Es ist schnell, es ist zuverlässig, keine Konflikte, nichts.
Also sie benutzen jetzt nicht mehr Core Data?
Nein, nein, sie haben sich von vornherein mal was Eigenes einfallen lassen. Und ich mag halt, also was ich mag, ist erstens, es ist, es ist, für die, also sehr einfache Dinge sind sehr einfach. Neue To Do anlegen, abhaken, fertig, ist alles genauso wie du das denkst. Alles geht erstmal in den Eingang rein. Dinge, die du für wichtig hältst, kannst du so in dieses, soll ich heute machen, hochziehen. Dann kannst du halt die Dinge in Projekte organisieren. Und du kannst diese Projekte wiederum in Bereiche organisieren. Das heißt, du hast so zwei Hierarchien, mit denen du das sozusagen trennst. Das heißt, ich habe so für mich so Bereiche, alles was meine Podcast-Produktion im weiteren Sinne betrifft. So Freak Show ist ein eigenes Projekt, wo ich dann halt auch meine Taschen immer wieder reinwerfe. Die werden halt so nie fertig. Aber ich habe dann zumindest so wie eine Zuordnung. Und kann halt auch sagen, ok, jetzt will ich mich mal nur um Dinge kümmern, die jetzt hier in diesem Kontext sind etc. Kann privates, persönliches, Familie und so weiter irgendwie alles brauchbar trennen. Wenn ich was abhacke, dann landet das in so einem Logbuch. Man sieht also auch, was man getan hat. Das ist nicht so weg, sondern es bleibt so ein Trail von Aktivitäten. Kann Dinge halt irgendwie wiederfinden. Und natürlich kannst du auch für Tasks sagen, wann die akut werden, wann die sozusagen ihre Deadline haben. Und kannst halt auch so einen Kalenderblick in die Zukunft sehen. Also funktioniert irgendwie alles gut.
Aber ehrlich gesagt, was mich an den meisten To Do-Listen immer stört, ist, ich brauche eigentlich das Feature, dass dieses muss getan werden. Aber um das zu tun, muss ich diese drei Dinge tun. Das heißt, dieses Item ist von den drei Dingen geblockt.
Setze dir doch einen Jira auf.
Und dieses Unterding ist wiederum geblockt von nochmal was anderem. Weil das alles auf eine Liste schreiben ist ja schön und gut. Aber wenn ich dann weiß, dass die Hälfte der Dinge kann ich gerade nicht machen, weil es da Voraussetzungen für gibt, für andere Dinge, die die blocken.
Dann musst du erstmal ein Projektmanagement Buch lesen.
Ja genau, weil was du da beschreibst, ist was anderes.
Das mag ja sein, aber das ist meine Anwendung.
Dann musst du ein Projektmanagement Tool machen.
Eine Liste von Punkten. Nein, keine Ganttschards. Ich will ein Regal aufhängen und die Dübel sind alle.
Oh, dann weißt du nicht, dass du dir erst Dübel kaufen musst, bevor du die Schrauben reinmachst?
Doch schon, aber ich brauche... Der Punkt Regal aufhängen ist auf der To Do Liste einfach mal geblockt. Es nützt mir nichts, dass dieser Punkt da rumhängt. Solange ich keine Dübel gekauft habe, will ich den Punkt Regal aufhängen nicht sehen.
Aber Roddy, du machst das wirklich. Schreib dir einfach einen neuen Punkt Dübel aufhängen, wenn du das aufhängst, über den Tars Regal aufhängen, dann hast du eine Prioritätenliste.
Ja, du hast eine Reihenfolge.
Also wirklich, das kann doch so lebensunfähig...
Nein, aber für mich ist das so ein grundlegendes Ding, was keine To Do Liste irgendwie kann.
Na, du kannst sie doch unter Ort...
Wie gesagt, eine Liste, Punkte, kann man auf Blattpapier machen.
Also Projektmanagement kann das. Da kannst du deine Dübelressourcen noch planen und einzelne Mitarbeiter...
Ich will nicht Ressourcen planen und Mitarbeiter zu haben. Demnächst vielleicht auch.
Du verplanst schon deine eigenen mentalen Ressourcen in dieser Dübelfrage schon enorm.
Aber du könntest doch, wenn wir bei diesem To Do Listen-Ding bleiben, was irgendwie so ein bisschen Hierarchie kann. Dann hast du ein Projekt, das heißt?
Ein Epic! Ich finde übrigens, kurzer Einschub, der Mensch, der es geschafft hat in Agile Development, wo alles total dynamisch und klein und schnuffig ist, das Wort Epic reinzufräsen, ist immer noch ein Genie.
Also, damit Huckel... Entschuldigung, damit Roddy seinen Epic Regal aufhängen kann.
Ja, ein Regal aufhängen ist kein Epic.
Jetzt ist es ein Epic.
Was ist denn ein Epic?
Ja, vor allen Dingen, das ist halt die Verkehrsrumme, Verkehrsrumme tarantinsweise. Weil ein Regal aufhängen ist kein Projekt, ist kein Projekt und es ist auch kein Epic, sondern das ist einfach nur ein To Do. Aber dieses To Do wird von einem anderen To Do blockiert.
Ich esse erst mal ein Stück Chili Schoki.
Bei dir scheint der Regal aufhängen aber schon sehr episch zu sein, wenn du mit deinem Was-Dübeln da...
Ihr habt immer gedacht über die Features, die Tim von Kalendern haben wollte. Jetzt darf ich mal mit To Do-Listen anfangen.
Deswegen lachen wir über dich auch.
Liste mit Abhängigkeiten.
Die waren überhaupt nicht lächerlich, meine Forderungen.
Das habe ich auch nie behauptet. Wir haben trotzdem gelacht.
Ich kann übrigens Wunderliste heutzutage auch nicht mehr leider so einwandfrei empfehlen. Das wurde ja irgendwann von Microsoft gekauft. Microsoft hat dann gesagt, wisst ihr was? Wir machen jetzt unsere eigenen To Do Liste und geben jetzt keine weiteren Ressourcen für Wunderliste aus. Die entwickeln zwar daran immer noch ein bisschen weiter und es funktioniert auch immer noch schnuffig, aber wahrscheinlich wird es irgendwann abgeschaltet. Und durch einen Outlook To Do List Manager ersetzt.
Outlist.
Outlist, wer weiß.
Das Schöne an Zynx ist, das ist halt immer noch bei Kalschat Code. Hamburg? Ich weiß es gerade gar nicht so genau. Stuttgart. Ich glaube ja.
Bei den Preisen eher aus Süddeutschland. Ja.
Also klar, jetzt kann man natürlich die Nase rümpfen und sagen, was? 50 Euro für ein Programm? Wo ich Checkboxen ausfülle und so? Ja, schon. Aber ich glaube gerade To Do Apps sind so ein wunderbares Beispiel dafür, was man, wo die Qualität eines Programms auch darin besteht, welche Features es nicht enthält. Also dieses genau, dieses nicht zu viel, nicht zu kompliziert.
Klar.
So, und da kann man schon...
Solange dir das dann auch wirklich dabei hilft, diese Sachen dann auch zu erledigen, die du alles schön reinschreibst, dann ist alles wunderbar.
Ja, und bisher funktioniert das relativ gut. Und ich muss sagen, dass die neue Version von Things, dieses Things 3, sieht halt auch einfach mal wirklich schmuck aus.
Und du kriegst noch mehr geschafft.
Tatsächlich.
Ja, wenn es so schmuck aussieht, natürlich.
Sind die alten Versionen untereinander kompatibel? Also wenn du auf dem Mac eine alte Version hast und auf dem iPhone eine neue?
Wenn da die Datenbanken nicht mehr zusammenpassen, wirst du zumindest relativ eloquent darauf hingewiesen, dass du doch mal...
Deine Kreditkarten einfach mal nur noch mal eins siehst.
Vielen Dank, dass Sie auch dieses Produkt gekauft haben.
Na ja, weiß ja, ohne Änderung kein Fortschritt.
Und das Protosozialprodukt.
Also muss man ausprobieren und gucken, ob es immer noch passt.
Ja, ich investiere ja relativ viel Geld in Softwarelösungen so generell und...
Ja, sonst noch gar nicht aufgefallen.
Tja, deswegen wurde es ja auch mal Zeit, dass ich darauf hingewiesen habe. So, so viel dazu.
Ja, der empfohlenen Task Warrior hat... Und OmniFocus hat bestimmt alles, was Roddy will, aber Task Warrior hat Blocking Tasks.
Ja, OmniFocus, dafür kann ich aber fünfmal Things kaufen, glaube ich.
Ja, aber da kannst du dann halt auch die Dübelproblematik sehr elegant lösen, ne? Mit der Verkehrsrumme.
Wie viel ist es dir wert, die Dübel in deinem Epic abzubilden?
Ich will keinen Epic. Ich habe auf Arbeit genug Epics.
Also Hornbach würde dir wahrscheinlich auch sagen, dass das ein größeres Projekt ist.
Ja, die wollen mir ja auch größeres Werkzeug dafür verkaufen.
Hast du dann schon eine richtige Makita gekauft? Oder die Hilti?
Nein, von Bosch natürlich die Professional Line, die blaue.
Die Verkehrsrumme, au.
Kommen wir zu etwas nicht völlig anderes mit Makita. Leute, der Witz ist durch jetzt.
Wir haben uns gerade über Werkzeug unterhalten.
Professional Werkzeug.
Seit wann ist denn Bosch besser als Makita?
Ich hab mal mit Charan geredet und sie meinen, die Munzen, weiß ich dann, nur Bosch blau, weil der Rest ist Müll.
Ein bisschen mehr Bums.
Makita ist kein.
Nein, es ist kein Müll. Das kannst du dir so für zu Hause kaufen.
Ist ja okay, ich hab's ja zu Hause.
Aber wenn du so ein Regal halt aufhängen willst, da brauchst du halt eine blaue Box.
Meine Makita hat bisher alles geschafft.
Was ist denn eine blaue Bosch?
Die Professional Line von Bosch.
Nicht das grüne Zeug, was du in Baumann kriegst, sondern das gute.
Das rechts unten.
Der heißt auch Blau.
Ja, sagt man so, ist aber eigentlich Bosch Professional.
Verstehe.
Ziemlich geiles Teil. Also wir haben da ja etwas älteres Modell.
Aber, Makita, Makita hat ein Baustellenradio, in das du betreiben kannst mit den Akkus, ich weiß.
Was viel geiler bei Makita ist, und das ist der Hit in der Kletterhalle, die haben einen Ventilator, den du auch mit den Akkus betreiben kannst.
Ist der so stark, dass der dir in der Kletterhalle was bringt?
Du kannst dir die Fingerchen dran kühlen, auf jeden Fall.
Aber er hebt dich nicht hoch.
Nee, das musst du schon noch selber machen. Aber die ganzen High-End-Kletterer denken sich halt so, lass uns mal die Finger davor kühlen, es ist so warm hier.
Ach, diese Kletterer. Ich war ja auch kürzlich mal klettern. Ja, da hat sich direkt... Klettern oder bouldern?
Mit oder ohne Seil?
Ohne.
Dann warst du bouldern.
Aber es hatte sich für mich so als Naivling auch ein bisschen wie Klettern angefühlt. Ja, da hat sich auch direkt gleich einer von diesen Kletterhengsten hat sich ein bisschen übernommen und ist irgendwie so auf seine Schulter gefallen, dass gleich in den ersten fünf Minuten muss der Notarzt kommen. Und alle, die sich vorher am Makita-Lüfter die Finger gekühlt haben, standen dann ganz besorgt um den Kletterhengst ringsrum. Ich habe mich gleich zuhause gefühlt.
Makita-Akkulüfter.
Die haben im Baustellen-Zubehör auf jeden Fall einige Punkte noch abgesandt. Das sieht man gelegentlich.
Makita ist schon ziemlich etabliert. Der Freund des Handwerkers. Da ist auch alles so korrekt gebaut.
Sind das die Japaner?
Makita? Gute Frage. Weiß ich gar nicht.
Aus Asien kommt doch sowieso alles. Am Ende. Kommt auch aus Malaysia oder so.
Japan!
Ja, Makita ist japanisch.
Dann ist es kein Wunder, dass alles akkurat ist, oder? Das ist quasi so die Bento-Box für den Handwerker.
Einer meiner Lieblingsstumpfen-Witze, den ich seit bestimmt 15 Jahren...
Den hatten wir auch schon mal, glaube ich.
Sicherlich, sicherlich. Den trage ich seit 15 Jahren, oder so mit mir rum und schmunzle immer wieder drüber.
Das sei ich doch, Bento-Box für Handwerker. Guck dir das an. Alles in Reihe und Glied. Das macht wahrscheinlich morgens auch vor der Arbeit noch Sport.
Was für ein Bitset.
No, ja, da ist einiges bei.
Da ist vor allem fast nichts mehr nicht drin.
Da haben wir einige Affiliate-Links zusammen gesammelt jetzt.
Genau. Kaufen Sie jetzt das Makita-Bora-Set. Nur 216 Teile. Moving on. Ich hab mir einen Akku gekauft, auf den wollte ich noch mal kurz hinweisen, weil ich das bemerkenswert finde, was es da mittlerweile alles so gibt.
Einen Akku.
Ja, einen Akku. Ja, weil ich hab ja dieses Wohnwagen-Strom-Backup-Problem, oder was heißt Problem? Herausforderung. Und dann hab ich mir halt so überlegt, hm.
Ach, wir reden jetzt nicht von einem iPhone-Ladeakku.
Na ja, das konvergiert halt alles schon ganz ordentlich. Weil, und jetzt müssen wir gleich mal ein bisschen, müssen wir alle, die besser sich mit Strom auskennen als ich, das sind so ziemlich alle wahrscheinlich.
Alle Hörer? Nee, hier, es gibt sogar eine Alkohol-Kaffee-Maschine, ist das echt?
Ich dachte gerade, es wäre eine Toilette.
Ja, alles was du halt auf der Baustelle brauchst, wo halt noch Geld drum ist, ne? Makita Akkumaschine ist geil. Kaffee Maschine, eine Akkumaschine wäre gut. Wo waren wir? Ah ja, Strom, genau. Und der Klassiker ist ja, dass du dir so eine Autobatterie-artige Batterie in deinen Wohnwagen gefährt stellst. So, und das sind dann so diese Gel-Blei-Akkus oder halt, was jetzt wohl so der Neu-Fisch-Brei ist, diese AGM-Dinger, das ist irgendwie so mit Glasfasermatten noch irgendwie, die können halt alle nicht mehr auslaufen wie diese normalen Flüssigbatterien, die man so in normalen Autos findet. Diese AGM-Batterien sind wohl auch ein ganz brauchbares Replacement für diese Nassbatterien, weil die halt auch diese entsprechenden hohen Startströme liefern, die du halt brauchst, um ein Auto zu starten. Die brauchst du natürlich jetzt im Wohnwagen nicht, wenn es nur darum geht, 12 Volt Backup-System für Stromwasserpumpe und so geringlastige Dinge zu haben. Trotzdem ist das so die Technologie, die man da normalerweise drin findet. Sprich, wenn du dich halt fragst, was brauche ich mir denn jetzt für einen Akku da rein? Na, kommt das? Da denkt man sich aber so, aber irgendwie Akku, da hat sich doch einiges getan. Dann habe ich mal so geschaut, was es so im Bereich Akkus gibt, die halt nicht nur 5 Volt für Handys liefern können.
Tesla Powerwall.
Na, soweit muss man gar nicht gehen, sondern es gibt halt mittlerweile auch genauso so Lithium-Ionen und Lithium-Polymer-Akkus, die eben auch 12 oder 20 Volt liefern und die dann eben auch als Akku-Pack für Laptops zum Beispiel gedacht sind.
Ja, ich kenne die jetzt nur so als Modell-Sport-Dinger, aber dann sind es halt nur Zellen, das sind keine richtigen...
Genau, zum Beispiel habe ich hier auf dem Tisch... Ein Akku, der so in etwa die Größe einer externen Festplatte hat.
Das sieht schon nach so einem typischen 3,5 Zoll externer Festplatte aus.
Könnte sogar ein DVD-Laufwerk einpassen.
Kommen da auch 12 Volt raus?
Da kommen auch 12 Volt, da kommen auch 20 Volt raus.
Interessant.
Und das ist jetzt von dem Hersteller Power Oak. Die haben auch noch fetzigere Lösungen. Also die haben so richtig so mobile Akkulösungen in verschiedenen Varianten. Haben auch so Sonnenkollektoren und Pipapo. Also kannst du halt auch mal so einen fetten Koffer irgendwie mit Akku irgendwo hinstellen, wenn du halt mal mobil mal Strom brauchst.
Das gibt es von Bosch Blau auch alles. Wirklich?
Ja, mag ja alles sein. Die Frage ist halt immer nur, für welche Stromanwendung.
Na die haben sowas um, denn auf so einer großen Baustelle, wo kein Strom da ist, damit alle Handwerker da ihre Batterien laden können, gibt es so einen großen Kasten, der mit, keine Ahnung, zwei Kilowatt irgendwie stellt in und dann können alle erstmal sich da bedienen.
Gut, aber das Power Org K2-Teil, was ich jetzt habe, das kommt halt mal mit 50.000 mAh daher. Also 50 Ampere Stunden. Und jetzt wird es ein bisschen haarig. Außerdem sagen sie noch, dass das 185 Wattstunden seien.
Ja.
Da weiß ich jetzt aber nicht, was sie da miteinander multiplizieren, um auf diese Zahl zu kommen.
Na, die Ausgangsspannung.
Genau, warten wir doch schon mal, Timme. Wie viel Volt hat das Ding? Kann man ja ausrechnen. 185 geteilt durch 50 und dann hast du die Volt. Siehst du, dann weißt du, was die Zellen da haben.
Naja, aber ich kann da ja auch mit 12 Volt und mit 20 Volt aus.
Ja, aber dann hast du halt...
Also Ampere-Stunden ist die reine Ladung.
50.
Also Ampere-Stunden ist die reine Ladung. Und Wattstunden ist halt der Energieinhalt.
Das heißt, wenn du 3,7 Volt nur brauchst, dann kannst du 185 Stunden lang einen Watt rausziehen.
Ja, die Ampere-Stunden beziehen sich ja sozusagen auf das, was da an Strom rausgeht, bei einem definierten Voltwert.
Nee, eigentlich bezieht es sich darauf, wie viele Elektronen da rauskommen. Weil Ampere...
Wir werden so viel Ärger kriegen.
Ampere ist ja Ladung pro Zeit. Ampere ist ja Ladung pro Zeit. Das heißt, Ampere-Stunden, wenn du das wieder mit der Zeit multiplizierst, dann ist die Menge Ladung, die da rauskommt. Und Watt ist ja eine Leistung. Und Watt-Stunden... Nee, Watt-Stunden... Moment.
Ist das Produkt von Ampere und Volt.
Das ist die Energie.
Genau, also wenn das Ding jetzt wirklich 185 Watt-Stunden hat, und ich schließe da jetzt ein Gerät an, wie zum Beispiel meine Fritz Box LTE, die kleine, Süße. Die, soweit ich das bisher messen konnte, ungefähr so zwischen 4 und 5 Watt verbraucht.
Ja, dann müsste sie...
185 geteilt wird.
2-3 Tage laufen.
Das mal und etwa das, was ich haben wollte.
Hast du schon gemessen?
Mit Verlusten und Zeug und weiß ich nicht...
Ja, mit Verlusten und Zeug hält das Ding auf jeden Fall 24 Stunden sicher.
Wahrscheinlich, ja.
Wenn ich jetzt aber so eine gel- 20 Kilogramm schwere Gel-Akku-Batterie habe, die ja auch mit 12 Volt angegeben ist, die kriegst du so ab 41 Ampere-Stunden und aufwärts.
12 mal 41 und dann hast du eine Wattstunde wieder.
Na ja, die hat jetzt 50 Ampere-Stunden, wenn die andere 40 Ampere-Stunden hat, dann hat die entsprechend 20 Prozent weniger.
Bei 12 Volt.
Weil die hat ja nur 3,7 Volt, deswegen ist ja die Wattstunde wichtig.
Nein, aber die Ladung ist ja die gleiche.
Sie nicht. Wattstunden ist also allgemeingültig, weil das ist das, was du an Leistung da rauskriegen kannst. Das heißt, Wattstunden ist entscheidend. Korrekt.
Man kann am Pär nur vergleichen, wenn auch die Spannung gleich ist.
Die Energiedichte ist bei Lipos wesentlich höher, explodieren halt auch spektakulärer. Also immer nur Wattstunden vergleichen, aber mir ist diese Rechnung hier so unklar. Ich habe mir überlegt, warum sollte ich mir da überhaupt noch so eine dusselige Gel-Batterie, die viel zu schwer ist, da reinbauen, wenn ich mir auch so eine Teile da reinbauen kann?
Weil das Teil da 200 Euro gekostet hat?
Also der kostet, den habe ich jetzt bei Amazon für 150 geschossen.
Okay, für 150, da kriegst du drei Autobatterien nehme ich an, oder? Oder zwei mindestens. Die beide irgendwie, wie viel, was hast du gesagt, 40 Ampere-Stunden bei 12 Volt haben, also 400 Wattstunden. Das heißt, jetzt dann 800 Wattstunden mit der, da hast du eine 185. Ganz einfache Rechnung.
Na ja.
Und die 40 Wattstunden ist wahrscheinlich eher wenig bei einer Autobatterie, oder? Das ist eine sehr kleine.
Na, sie wiegen ja auch irgendwie das Zehnfach.
Ja, das schon.
So, und Gewicht ist halt auch mal nicht ganz interessant.
Wenn du Gewicht haben willst, dann musst du ja diese Live-Pro-Akkus holen, was ich auch schon mal erzählt habe, was ich in mein Motorrad eingebaut habe. Aber die haben halt noch weniger Kapazität. Die haben zwar sehr viel Strom, den sie raushauen können, aber sie haben nicht so eine hohe Kapazität.
Ja, und sie haben nicht so viele Ladezyklen.
Zum Anlass ist es, doch, haben sie schon.
Nee, Bleiakkus haben weniger Ladezyklen als WC-Mio.
Ach so, die Bleiakkus, ich meine jetzt von den Live-Pro-Akkus, die haben Ladezyklen ohne Ende.
LiPo-Akkus haben deutlich mehr Ladezyklen als Bleiakkus. Also da bist du auf jeden Fall dann auch auf der sicheren Seite. Jetzt mal abgesehen davon, dass du sowieso nicht schaffst, zu viele Ladezyklen auf die Batterie drauf zu kriegen, dass es einen Unterschied machen würde.
Weil ich fand ja hier hat gerade ein User hier, der B-Nutzer hat gerade hier auch noch so eine Batterie reingepostet. Die hat zwar nur quasi die Hälfte des Ganzen, aber kann dafür auch AC und DC, den wollen wir mal ein bisschen höher, Omni-Charge noch ein bisschen höher. Das ist vielleicht ja auch durchaus spektakulär und kriegt halt auch ordentlich Volt und Zeug so da durchgepumpt. Also hat halt auch tatsächlich, ich meine, das ist halt US-Socket leider, das ist der, also für den AC-Teil. Warte mal, ich, hier gibt es so eine Seite, wo so die Tech-Specs stehen. Wie habe ich denn das gerade gefunden?
Ja, aber ein Wechselrichter ist ja jetzt auch keine riesige Anstattung.
Ich finde halt nur, das ist so, genau, wenn du auf diese Omni 20 klickst, das ist das mit dem meisten Strom, war das jetzt die Seite, die ich da gefunden habe? Ja genau, da gibt es dann auch so die Tech-Specs und alles Mögliche. Und ja, es wäre jetzt halt schön, wenn das nicht so eine US-Buchse gewesen wäre, aber auch ein interessantes Konzept, was es da nicht alles gibt heutzutage. Also weil der kann halt, wo stand das jetzt gerade, wie viel Volt der raushaut?
Ja gut, da habe ich ja jetzt, ich meine, ein Akku zu haben, der dann 220 Volt, oder in dem Fall 110 Volt wahrscheinlich, naja, macht sogar 220 Volt, ne?
In der entsprechenden Variante.
Mit Euro-Stecker. So, und dann steckst du da gleich wieder ein Netzteil rein, der das dann wieder nochmal in Wärme umwandelt, ne, will man eigentlich nicht. Mir geht es ja jetzt konkret um 12 Volt.
Der hat ja auch alle möglichen anderen Stecker noch dran, ne? Also, das ist halt der an der NX-Pipe.
Der USB halt.
Ne, es gibt auch Barrel-Ports für DC. An einer Seite. Also, das ist halt schon, genau, da gibt es hier einmal Barrel-Port mit 4,5 bis 36 Volt, und dann gibt es noch einen mit bis 3 Ampere. Und dann gab es, glaube ich, noch einen zweiten, genau, von 1 bis 24 Volt. Also, ist halt auch ein sehr, äh, äh, versatiles Gerät.
Geht in die gleiche Richtung. Dieser Power-Oak, der hat einen 12 Volt-Ausgang, 20 Volt-Ausgang und nochmal 4x USB mit, ähm, mal gucken, wie die spezifiziert sind, mit 2x 2,1 Ampere.
Das ist jetzt der K2, den du da hast, ne?
Das LTE-Ding hast du da auch gerade dran, ja?
Ja, ich mach jetzt einen Dauertest.
Und die Stecker mit Adapter, irgendwie, wie hast du die gemacht?
Die waren dabei.
Die waren dabei, weil ich hab auch schon überlegt, weil man hatte schon gesagt, das Ding, das LTE-Teil, braucht, also wenn sich die Hörer erinnern, wir haben das ja von AVM hier uns, äh... Du nicht. Ja, ich hab jedenfalls so ein Ding geschenkt bekommen, hab ein bisschen geforscht und das braucht wahrscheinlich gar keine 12 Volt, sondern weniger, weil da ist nichts drin, was 12 Volt braucht. Du könntest mal probieren, ob du dem Ding mal so 5 geben kannst und ob es dann immer noch funktioniert.
Na gut, ich mein, es wird mit einem 12 Volt Netzteil ausgeliefert.
Macht ja nix.
Ja, aber 5 ist wahrscheinlich zu wenig.
Also wenn sie 5 gebraucht hätten, hätten sie bestimmt einen 5 Volt Netzteil beigelegt.
Ja, wäre ich mir halt nicht so sicher.
Äh, ist mir egal. Hab ich jetzt und deswegen hab ich mir das jetzt zugelegt und jetzt mach ich halt hier grad so ein bisschen Dauertest. Ich hatte vorher noch einen anderen Akku, der hat aus irgendwelchen Gründen immer wieder abgeschaltet. Das scheint jetzt hier, äh, zumindest bisher nicht mehr der Fall zu sein. Und ja, ich bin gespannt, wie lange das so hält. Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass es so ein paar Tage durchhält, so.
Na, hast du auf die Web-Oberfläche mal geguckt, da steht ja da, wie viel der Stromverbrauch gerade ist und so.
Nee, da steht das nur in Prozent.
Achso, ja stimmt, stimmt.
Völlig beknackt.
Ist das jetzt eigentlich noch eine über?
Hast du schon ein Firmware-Update gemacht? Sonst geht es nämlich mit O2-Karten, nicht? So ging es mir erstmal.
Alles schon gemacht. Das ist auf jeden Fall eine interessante Lösung. Und ich finde auch so diese Lösung mit so einem Akku, den ich sozusagen überall, wo ich so 220 Volt habe, kann ich halt so ein Akku dezentral positionieren und für so einzelne Backup-Bereiche bereitstellen.
Überall, wo du was hast?
Überall, wo ich 230 Volt habe in dem Wohnwagen. Ach so. Ich leg so ein Ding hin, dann lädt es da an der Stelle und liefert da den entsprechenden Strom für, was auch immer, für Geräte. Also Power Oak macht auf jeden Fall einen ganz ordentlichen Eindruck. Und vielleicht habt ihr ja auch so einen Bedarf. Gibt es irgendwie in verschiedenen Größen, gibt es auch gleich noch mit Solarzellen dabei. Und hat vor allem also Kapazität, die so überzeugt. Weil es ist nicht so, ich kann zwei, drei Mal mein Ding laden, sondern du hast halt einfach so ein Scheißteil. Das lädt auch so acht Stunden, bis es so voll ist. So, aber wenn du das mitnimmst, dann bist du safe für dein Wochenende. Und ich hab mir jetzt auch noch ein Adapterkabel für MacBook Air gekauft. Mal gucken, ob das funktioniert, wenn ich damit halt auch noch mein MacBook Air laden kann, dann bin ich so richtig froh.
Dieses, das Ding jetzt, dein Power Card 2, was die 12 Volt kann, was ist denn die kleinste Version, die 12 Volt kann, womit ich sozusagen auch das LTE-Ding irgendwie anschließen kann?
Ähm, von den Oxy's?
Ich glaub, es gibt da noch eine 36er, die ist aber nur so unwesentlich billiger.
Find ich gar nicht. Oder muss man auf die Power-Aug raufklicken und dann kommen alle verschiedenen?
Nee, das nicht.
Aber der hat auch schon USB-C. Tut sich gerade was.
Hier, das hier ist das 36er, aber das hat keine 12 Volt, oder?
Ja, nee, das scheint wohl dann doch das Einzige.
Doch, hier, 12 Volt, 3 Ampere, Typ C. Na ja, okay, bräuchte man einen Adapter von Typ C auf, also USB Typ C, ne? Nehm ich mal an, auf diesen Schnupsi von dem LTE-Ding. Ich muss das mal austesten, ob das LTE-Ding auch weniger als 12 Volt kann. Ich schätze mal schon, kann bestimmt bis 6 runtergehen, oder so.
So, nächstes Thema.
Ja, kurze Themen-Begrete. So mach ich das ja immer, wenn ne Pause da ist. Kennt ihr schon den besten Shortcut in Slack?
Den besten Shortcut in Slack?
Was ist denn euer Lieblings? Abgesehen von Apfel Kuh?
Apfel Punkt. Was macht denn Apfel Punkt?
Tim weiß das.
Apfel Punkt ist das Abbrechen eines Vorgangs. Aber ich meine, Slack tut ja nichts.
Dann wieder Apfel Kuh.
Okay, ihr kennt den besten Shortcut in Slack nicht. Es ist Shift-Esc.
Okay, und was macht das?
Probier's aus.
Ich hab's nicht an. Ich hab jetzt hier Slack auf der Webseite offen, was keine gute Idee ist.
Aber wir, all Androids?
Ich bin ja in vielen Slack-Kanälen bisweilen zugange. Und auch so Teams und so weiter. Und es gibt halt immer diese Kanäle, wo dir irgendwelche Leute irgendwas rein brabbeln, den ganzen Channel notifizieren. Und du hast tausende Notifications, tausende Unread Messages. Und es macht mich ja wahnsinnig, wenn da irgendwie so rote Blöbbel sind. Und ich weiß eigentlich schon gleich genau... Ja, aber ey, das sind so viele. Ich will meine Zeit nicht damit verbringen, diese ganzen Channels immer zu muten. Und mit Shift-Esc ist dieses Problem einfach in Sekundenschnelle. Also in einer Sekunde oder noch weniger. Weil, einfach mark as red on all. Und weiter geht's mit dem Glücklichsein. Also wenn ihr auch zu der Spezies gehört, die dir leicht gestresst davon ist, wenn da zu viele Unread Messages und zu vielen Slack-Kanälen sich aufhäufen. Shift-Esc. Und der Tag ist gerettet.
Und die, die wichtig sind, liest du aber vorher noch?
Also ich hab ja meistens in diesen Teams gibt es ein bis zwei Kanäle, die mich betreffen. Der Rest ist ja so Fnord. Und dann meinen aber Leute, in diesen Fnord-Channels halt auch mit Add Channel oder Add Here alle zu notifizieren zu müssen.
Die kriegen eigentlich immer auf...
Auf den Finger. Oder man geht aus den Channels halt raus. Wie gesagt, ich kann nur berichten, ich hab mittlerweile so eine kleine Slack-Overload-Problematik. Und Shift Escape ist für mich das Simpelste.
Also bei uns kriegt Add Channel auf jeden Fall jemand auf den Finger. Weil Add Channel hat ja das Problem, dass er tatsächlich Push-Notifications an alle angeflossenen Devices schickt. Add Here notifiziert ja nur die Leute, die Slack gerade offen haben. Das geht ja noch. Das geht ja dann noch. Aber es ist trotzdem auch nicht nett, wenn irgendwie... Ja, und dann gibt's halt die Channels, wo man quasi eingeladen wird, jetzt schlecht Nein sagen kann, und dafür gibt's die Mute-Taste.
Ja, aber...
Ich hab relativ viele Channels einfach gemutet.
Das war's auch schon, ne? Shift, Escape. Ich kannte den nicht. Ich war sehr froh, als ich ihn kennenlernen durfte. Ich glaube, über Twitter irgendwie ist was an mir vorbeigerauscht, und ich bin sofort... Hab ich mich verliebt. Weiter geht's.
Weiter geht's. Letty, jetzt müssen wir mal über Personal reden.
Über Personal.
Wir haben am Wochenende, aus irgendeinem Grund, sind wir auf, das Thema Teams gekommen und Teams in Projekten und wie man eigentlich ein gutes Team, also woran man vielleicht ein gutes Team erkennt, wie man sich ein gutes Team zusammenbaut für ein Projekt. Also bei mir ist halt häufig das Problem, dass ich ja kurze Forschungsprojekte habe und dass es eigentlich schwer ist, sich in so einer kurzen Zeit auch meistens einzugrooven als Team, dass es halt irgendwie passt. Und auch so die Konstellationen, also ich hab jetzt gerade ein Team, was aus 2, 2,5 Personen besteht.
Perfekt.
Naja, ein Entwickler, ein Programmierer und der Entwickler soll... Das andere, ein Designer und ein Entwickler. Und am besten sollte natürlich einer auch Projektmanagement machen. Und so eine Dinge bleiben halt immer an einer Person dann hängen. Und ich weiß gar nicht, wie wir darauf gekommen sind.
Ich hab zunächst einmal überhaupt festgestellt, dass du da sozusagen... Also du hast, glaube ich, geklagt, dass du da die Programmiererin bist und dann gibt es noch den Designer. Und das ist sozusagen wie so eine Uni, dass dann auch sieht, das muss doch reichen, sind doch alle Bereiche abgedeckt. Und das kann man natürlich mal machen. Und das hat immer so ein bisschen auch was vom Scope und von der Dauer zu tun. Aber irgendwann so als Programmierer, bisher dann so in so einem...
In so einem Käfig sitzen, etwas degeneriert und man denkt so...
Keiner redet mehr mit mir. Dann wirst du halt einfach nur noch so hospitalisiert, fängst du an da irgendwie so auf deinem Stuhl rumzuwippen, weil du halt einfach nicht mehr mit normalen Menschen reden kannst.
Wovon redest du?
Aber Austausch.
Genau, der Austausch. Also ich habe in dem Projekt davor gab es einen Designer, der sich aber auch Coden einfach beigebracht hat. Wir sind ja viel im Interfacesign bzw. Visualisierungsprogramm unterwegs. Und der hat sich einfach irgendwann beigebracht, wie man mit D3 codet, also JavaScript und ein bisschen Web Development. Aber er wusste zum Beispiel, weil ich zum Prototypen, häufig Angular nutze, zum Beispiel nicht, wie er das als Beispiel benutzt. Da hatten wir so einen kleinen Austausch, aber dann war die Person natürlich weg. Und jetzt sitzt man dann halt so da, wie Tim schon sagte, weißer Land anstarrnd. Nein, so schlimm nicht. Aber das ist echt so ein Problem, was man dann irgendwann so merkt, dass einem der Austausch fehlt und man irgendwie auf der Stelle einfach stehen bleibt. Und gerade in so einem Kontext einer, vielleicht gerade bei mir jetzt so Design-Department, da gibt es keine Informatiker oder da gab es mal ein paar Leute, die auch programmieren konnten, die jetzt auch weg sind. Man sitzt dann einfach da und denkt, super, toll.
Aber dann ist ja das Problem erkannt, die Lösung ist eigentlich auch bekannt, aber gibt es halt kein Geld von der Uni für einen zweiten Programmierer?
Das Problem ist ja, dass auf einer Seite, aber auf der anderen Seite vielleicht auch, selbst in anderen Teams hast du, ich weiß nicht, das kommt ja immer auf die Projekte an, aber meistens schon, eigentlich solltest du einen Programmierer haben und hast dann so einen halben Programmierer. Also das ist halt echt ein massives Problem, was wir jetzt auch wieder haben. Wir suchen halt auch gerade Leute, jemanden zu finden, der auch programmieren kann und vielleicht aber Design nicht als IG weg damit sieht. Also ich meine, das hatte ich halt auch in Teams, die designen als etwas überflüssiges.
Bei jeder vernünftigen Programmierer wird es schnell lernen, dass e-Design weg damit geht, weil es voll schlimm ist.
Ich meine, ich komme ja daher aus dieser Design-Welt.
Machst du einmal, dann willst du nie wieder Design machen, weil dann immer nur dein Hauptdesigner ankommt und sagt, ja, hast ja alles schön gemacht, aber der Kunde will es jetzt doch.
Ja, das kannst du nochmal alles so machen.
Das fand ich nicht so das Problem.
Ich meine, ich kenne ja auch beide Seiten. Das hat mir ja immer großen Spaß gemacht, zwischen den Welten auch zu vermitteln, weil ich irgendwie immer beide Seiten verstanden habe und gemerkt habe, warum die aneinander vorbei reden. Das war bei Art & Com tatsächlich auch zu meiner Zeit dort sehr verbreitet, dass die Entwickler so hehehehe und die Designer hehehehe. Eigentlich reden sie vom Gleichen, aber benutzen halt anderes Vokabular und andere Erwartungshaltung und reden so komplett aneinander vorbei. Dann könnte man immer so schön sagen, Leute, ihr wollt eigentlich das Gleiche, ihr sagt auch das Gleiche nur anders und so. Aber ja, da ist halt, also unverbrauchte junge Leute, das sind dann vielleicht das einzige Mittel, das dann ein glückliches Händchen haben. Also ich hatte zum Beispiel bei VUGA, wo ich ja auch so Job-Interviews gemacht habe für neue Kandidaten, da gab es glaube ich in der ganzen Zeit zwei Leute, die fit waren und wo mir auch total egal war, was sie studiert haben oder wie auch immer, sondern da hast du einfach so gemerkt, die sind so auf Zack, die sind noch unverbraucht, die sind noch offen für alles.
Die gehe ich jetzt mal versauen.
Ja, also die haben tatsächlich, wenn man sich heute mit denen unterhält, ist von dieser jugendlichen Offenheit und Unverbrauchtheit nicht mehr viel übrig geblieben. Die haben auch schon sehr festgefahrene Meinungen mittlerweile von dem, was toll ist und was nicht toll ist. Aber mit denen kann man dann schon so ein halbes Jahr lang was wuppen.
Ja, also mit den Leuten, mit denen ich jetzt das aktuelle Projekt mache und das davor, das war halt auch extrem cool. Und mit denen kann man was wuppen. Aber wir merken selber beide, dass dem Designer, dem fehlt ein anderer Designer, um darüber zu reden. Weil klar kann er mir nochmal einen Vortrag überhalten, was der Unterschied zwischen Kerning und Sperren in der Typo ist. Aber das merke ich mir einmal, guckt doof und guckt beim zweiten Mal immer noch leicht doof. Beim dritten Mal kann ich immer noch nicht mitreden. Und er auch genauso auf der anderen Seite nicht. Wenn ich meine, was nehme ich jetzt hier für ein Framework dafür? Was meinst du, was soll ich fürs Backend nehmen? Lieber eine Postgres oder eine MySQL-Daten? Dann kommt von ihm, du hast den Semicolon vergessen und geht weg. Aber es ist halt so ein bisschen das Problem in Teams. Wie findet man überhaupt so ein gutes Team, was funktioniert? Und was ist vielleicht auch so eine Mindestanforderung an Leuten, die man eigentlich haben muss in so einem Team? Also Anforderungen, vielleicht nicht Mindestanzahl, weiß ich nicht.
Also ich finde ja die optimale Teamgröße für sozusagen die Disziplinen, die unter sich sind. Bei VUGA war es ja so, da ist es auch immer noch so. Da sitzt ja das ganze Team zusammen. Designer, Product People, Backend, Frontend und so weiter. Und die gibt es immer im Paar. Und es gab ganz selten mal drei Backend-Entwickler und ganz, ganz selten vier. Und vier fand ich schon zu viel, drei geht noch so. Also bei vier merkt man den Overhead deutlich. Bei drei ist der Overhead verschmerzbar. Bei zwei, wenn man so einigermaßen gleichklickt, kann man Kühe fliegen lassen. Also zwei pro Disziplin fand ich bisher das Ideale. In Sachen Reibungsversuch und Effizienz.
Zwei Leute schaffen ungefähr das Doppelte von einem. Fünf schaffen ungefähr das Doppelte von zwei. Zehn, naja, sagen wir 20 ungefähr, das Doppelte von fünf.
Das ist wie mit den CPU-Cores.
Es wird immerhin effektiver.
Aber es kommt auch ein bisschen auf die Probleme an, oder? Manchmal gibt es so schicke Sachen, da kannst du einem vom Team sagen, hier mach mal das, kannst du in eine Woche wegsperren, dann kommt er wieder und ist fertig. Also gibt es ja auch so eine Jobs.
Zwei ist ja jetzt nicht nur das Doppelte von eins, sondern du ermöglichst ja eine ganz andere Arbeitskultur. Also ich hab das jetzt selber nicht so viel gemacht, aber ich hatte auch mal ein Softwareprojekt, wo ich quasi im Wesentlichen einen Pier hatte. Also wo der andere im Wesentlichen mit demselben Aufgabengebiet, also man hat sich schon Dinge noch geteilt, also aufgeteilt, aber man war halt in derselben Problemdomäne zu Hause. Jeder verstand die Probleme des anderen, weil man sie im Prinzip auch genauso haben könnte. Und die extremere Form davon ist ja dieses Pair Programming. Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das irgendwie so in dem Maße auch durchaktaziert. Was ich eigentlich besonders geil finde, dass eigentlich einer nur zuguckt und der andere schreibt den Code.
Das klingt jetzt ein bisschen zu passiv, weil du unterhältst dich ja dabei auch viel. Das heißt, du hast ja die ganze Zeit auch den Austausch.
Ja, selbstverständlich wollte ich auch hinzufügen. Dass man ja im Prinzip schon die Zeit nutzt, während der andere schreibt, dass man selber schon drüber nachdenkt, ob das irgendwie auch richtig ist. Und dann ja in diesem Prozess schon so, ja, ne, du legst mal lieber so an oder mach mal da noch mal eine separate.
Und du hast halt automatisch den Wissenstransfer.
Genau, du hast auch automatisch das Backup. Das heißt, wenn dir mal einer kaputt geht und so weiter, geht dir halt nicht gleich, ich kann ja sein. Irgendwie Urlaub, all die ganzen Sachen.
Der Busfaktor meinst du ja? Der Busfaktor.
Der Busfaktor, der kommt auch noch mit rein. Also im Prinzip kann man auf deine Frage antworten. Ihr müsst euch verdoppeln.
Also ganz so einfach ist es natürlich nicht, aber wenn ihr wirklich nur zu zweit seid, ein Designer, ein Programmierer ist natürlich sowieso schwierig. Besonders wenn ihr eigentlich beide in eurem Silo seid. Und wenig Berührungsflächen habt.
Also wie gesagt, du kannst halt da, ich habe auch schon gute Erfahrungen gemacht, wenn so ein Senior und ein Junior-Developer dabei sind, wo du den anderen oder die andere gleichzeitig mit ein bisschen hochlevelst. Wenn die halt fit sind und merkst, kannst du halt irgendwie Dinge sagen, und die saugen das auch direkt auf und sind nicht so wie das Schwein vorm Uhrwerk. Gibt es halt beide extremer, ich hatte da zweimal richtig Glück, aber auch schon mindestens genauso auf Pech, wo du denkst, ok, ich habe es jetzt gerade zum dritten Mal erklärt, das ist entweder nicht angekommen, wollte nicht angekommen werden sein, verstehen usw. oder keine Ahnung, andere Interessensgebiete, was auch immer, und dann bringt es halt Null und verlangsamt eher nur.
Ja, so einen kleinen Gimp, der nicht mehr mit Hochlevel, das wäre super.
Genau. Die wissen auch noch nicht so, was man im freien Markt so verdienen kann.
Das ist aber auch in der Tat so ein Problem, wo ich halt manchmal denke, boah, blöd, dass man im öffentlichen Dienst arbeitet, weil man häufiger an den Punkt kommt, wo die dann Leute sagen, was verdiene ich? Und du denkst dir dann so, ich hätte euch aber ganz gern, ihr seid gut und ich will nur nicht wieder das, was übrig bleibt haben.
Ja, aber da ist eigentlich, finde ich ja, so ein eigentlich ein cooler Zwischenraum für Leute, die halt vielleicht jetzt noch Bock auf Studieren haben und fit sind, aber halt nicht irgendwie diese scheiß Studenten-Jobs machen wollen. Wenn man dann ein cooles Projekt hat, dann sind die unter Umständen vielleicht sogar sehr dankbar. Also es ist schwierig. Es ist so wie mit Wohnungen finden in Berlin gerade wahrscheinlich.
Nicht möglich?
Doch, da gibt es halt auch so einen komischen Sweet Spot, habe ich festgestellt, also jetzt Angaben ohne Gewehr, aber es gibt so Wohnungen, die sind nicht WG geeignet und zu klein für Frau, Mann und Kind oder Mann, Mann und Kind und was auch immer. Und mit Durchgangszimmer und so weiter. Und für einen Studenten alleine zu teuer. So und für einen, der aber schon irgendwie einen Vollzeitjob oder sowas hat, eigentlich bezahlbar und groß genug und so weiter. Und da gibt es immer noch welche von.
Wo wir bei Teams und Jobs waren... Ich gehe mal kurz aufs Klo. Ich habe das hier... Ich habe das hier noch nicht erzählt, aber ich habe ja so ein bisschen den Job gewechselt innerhalb des Unternehmens und bin jetzt Teamleiter geworden. Und suche jetzt noch einen iOS-Entwickler. Also wer mich schon immer mal als Chef haben wollte, der kann sich bewerben.
Wir suchen in der Tat auch gerade für ein Forschungsprojekt, das drei Jahre lang gehen wird, zusammen mit dem Potsdamer Institut für Klimafolgenforschung. Sowohl Interface-Designer, also wirklich Interface-Design, mehr aus der Designrichtung kommt, auch gerne mit Affiliate zum Kundenkontakt. Sowas scheut sich ja der gemeine Nerd davor, mit Menschen zu reden. Ne, als auch, wie Huckel eigentlich sagte, noch so eine zweite Person, die nicht abgeneigt ist von Design, aber eben auch coden kann. So ein bisschen die Schnittstelle zwischen den zwei Welten auch ist. Die sind aber selten. Ja, die sind selten. Und an der Hochschule gab es auch immer wieder mal so ein paar, aber du findest denjenigen und dann werden sie weggefischt. Dann denkst du dir so, dammit, wieder zu langsam. Also genauso diese Schnittstelle zwischen Design und Programmierung. Also derjenige muss quasi keine Systeme selber wuppen, sondern eher so ein bisschen prototypen können, Ideen halt mit einbringen ins Projekt. Und der Themenschwerpunkt ist so Klimafolgenforschung und Klimawandel und da auch so ein bisschen die Kommunikation, was Klimawandel eigentlich heißt. Mit Visualisierung von Daten, speziell auf Klimamodellen, als auch so eine Webseite-Plattform anzubieten für verschiedene Akteure in der Politik oder auch in NGOs. Da suchen wir auch noch zwei Leute, also Interfest-Designer, reine Designer.
Also Welt retten und mit Lety zusammenarbeiten.
Und vielleicht auch nicht abgeneigt sein von Schokolade, denn das gibt es auch immer häufig im Büro.
Mit Chili.
Naja, die gibt es nicht so.
Und Uni bezahlen. Uni bezahlen, yeah.
Das macht doch nicht wieder alles schlecht.
Jetzt machen wir das.
Bei mir gibt es immerhin längere Arbeitsweg, aber dafür Bezahlung aus der freien Wirtschaft.
Dein Arbeitsweg ist ja kürzer.
Wie?
Na, wir haben doch schon mal festgestellt, wir sehen uns ab und zu im Regio. Also ich sehe dich ausstrecken.
Wie war das, Potsdam raus, ja?
Ja, Wahnsinn. Eine iOS-Stelle und eine Android-Stelle, also Android, da sind da nicht meine Leute. Aber suchen wir auch jemand. Nee, suchen wir auch. Nicht nehmen wir auch, sondern suchen wir auch.
Ja, Roddy, hättest du vor sieben Jahren mal gefragt, dann hätten wir mal reden können, aber jetzt.
Tja, vor sieben Jahren, da wusste noch, da hat das ja noch keiner ernst genommen mit dem iOS.
Aber diese Firma hat ja lebensgefährliche Glastür. Ich weiß nicht, ob das irgendwie eine gute Idee ist.
Ich bin jetzt in einem anderen Gebäude. Da sind die nicht mehr so lebensgefährliche Glastür.
Haben die jetzt diese Vogelaufkleber drauf?
Ja, nee.
Ich hab tatsächlich Vogelaufkleber gekauft. Die wollte ich eigentlich auf diese Glastür noch drauf machen. Genau, also wer sich da angesprochen fühlt.
Willst du dich nochmal Girlcon Crypto einspielen? Die ist so toll.
Traust du das immer?
Nee, aber wie sie schon Cryptocurrency ausspricht, finde ich super. Ist egal. Die ist schon ein bisschen so ein Mem geworden, glaube ich. Ja, Bitcoin. Interessiert ja keinen mehr, deswegen reden wir da gar nicht drüber. Jetzt gibt es ja was Neues.
Wieso interessiert das keinen?
Wo muss ich investieren?
ByteBalls heißt die Sache.
Hast du aber schon mal von erzählt.
Ja, aber nur vor der Sendung, ne?
Was sind denn ByteBalls?
ByteBalls ist eine neue Währung. Die ist auch ein bisschen anders als Bitcoin. Die funktioniert mit einem DAG, Direct Acyclic Graph. Ist egal. Klickt mal bei ByteBall Org. Sie ist nicht einfach so eine Bitcoin-Kopie, sondern ist schon was eigenständiges, so wie Ethereum oder Monero oder so andere eigenständige Cryptocurrencies. Also kein simpler Bitcoin-Fork. Hat einige interessante Aspekte. Was jetzt wichtig ist für die Leute, die schon Bitcoins besitzen, sie benutzen nämlich einen Verteilungssystem, was nicht basiert auf Mining, so wie bei Bitcoin. Bitcoin ist hier immer noch nicht fertig ausgeschüttet, sondern man muss halt hier inzwischen mit Asics irgendwie Bitcoins minen. Diese ByteBalls, die werden nicht gemeint, sondern die werden verteilt einfach so. Und jetzt ist der Witz, sie werden natürlich nicht einfach so verteilt, sondern an Leute, die schon Bitcoins haben. Das heißt, wenn ihr Bitcoins habt, müsst ihr euch bei dieser Webseite mal einlesen, wie das funktioniert. Dann könnt ihr dann diese Wallet installieren, da in so einem Chat mit so einem Bot reden, dem über so eine Methode beweisen, dass ihr Bitcoins habt. Und dann kriegt ihr beim nächsten Mal, wenn diese ByteBalls ausgeschüttet werden, und das passiert jedem Vollmund, und zwar am nächsten Mal...
Vollmund!
Diesen Sonntag. Genau, Tim, ich kenne dich aus. Kriegt ihr dann ByteBalls ausgeschüttet. Und das sollte man tun, weil das ist nicht so unwesentlich.
Aber so viel wie man Bitcoins hat, oder nur, man muss nur sagen, dass man irgendwelche hat?
Nee, so viel wie du hast.
Das wird ja bei mir nicht so viel.
Ja, zu dem Zeitpunkt, da wo die das bestimmen, also wenn Vollmund ist, machen die einen Snapshot von der Bitcoin-Datenbank mehr oder weniger. Also die legen einen bestimmten Blog fest. Und dann gehen sie da durch und gucken, alles klar, hier Huckel hat folgende Adresse angegeben, was so seine Bitcoins wären. Also deine Adresse halt. Dann gucken die nach, alles klar, da lagen 0,7 Bitcoins und dann kriegst du... Dann kriegst du entsprechend Byte-Balls irgendwie in deine Wallet da gestrungen.
Aber das ist doch scheiße, dann werden die Reichen noch reicher.
Ja, so ist es. Der Teufel scheißt immer auf den dicksten Haufen.
Kannst du mir ein paar Bitcoins leihen für die...
Du bist monofarückt.
Nur für die Vollmund-Ausschüttung. Und dann kriegst du die wieder. Du hast doch genug. Du kriegst die dann wieder, dann kriegst du bei der nächsten Ausschüttung...
Der Witz ist, dass wir das halt jeden Vollmund machen. Der zweite Witz ist, dass man für die Bitballs, die man schon hat, kriegt man beim nächsten Mal, also jetzt an diesem Sonntag, 20 Prozent obendrauf.
Aber du musst mich ja nur einmal hochleveln.
Ach, geh weg.
Wir teilen uns die Garage, man.
Und ich hab dir angeboten, Krypto-Unterschicht. Das sind alle Zeugen. Ich hab dem Hucke gesagt, ich kann dir das anstatt einen Euro in Bitcoins geben. Ich erinnere mich, der Kurs war bei ca. 750 Euro. Hucke so, nee, nee, gib mir das mal einen Euro. Alter, ich hab's dir gesagt.
Ja, aber jetzt geht's ja um ganz andere Beträge hier. Sag mal, du hast angenommen, du hättest... Also weißt du, das ist ja nur einmal. Du kriegst hier die Bitcoins nicht wieder.
Wie lang ist es?
So ein Arsch, der Dennis.
Ich hab hier keine Chance beim Paten heute.
Beim was? Beim Paten?
Beim Paten.
Ja, wirklich.
Da kriegt man, wenn man jetzt mal auf die Simpler umgerechnet, wenn man jetzt 16 Bitcoins hat, dann kriegt man genau die Menge von einem Gigabyte Byte Balls, also eine Milliarde Bytes, bei denen ist die Einheit, das ist ein Byte, kriegt man eine Milliarde Byte Balls. Und das sind zurzeit 750 Euro. Für umsonst, für nichts tun. Du musst nur beweisen, dass du diese Bitcoins hast.
Warum?
Einfach so?
Nein, warum existiert das?
Wir drehen die Sache andersrum. Stell dir vor, du hast eine Kryptowährung erschaffen. Die hat ein paar coole Features. Die hat ein paar Contractgeschichten eingebaut. Gar nicht so uninteressant. Muss man sich mal durchlesen, wo man so schicke Sachen mitmachen kann.
Bitcoins.
Kannst du ja alles ausnehmen. Genug Altcoins gibt es ja. Er hat jetzt diese coole Währung als Programm. Er muss ja damit anfangen. Er muss dafür sorgen, dass Leute die benutzen. Es gibt eine Möglichkeit, man kann ihn meinen. Fand er aber nicht so gut Stromkosten und so weiter. Fand er doof. Die nächste Möglichkeit ist, er kann es einfach so verteilen. Dann hat es wahrscheinlich aber keinen Wert, weil dann haben irgendwie gleich alle welche. Du willst ja auch, dass deine Währung einen Wert kriegt. Weil er will ja selber wahrscheinlich auch ein bisschen verdienen. Und seine Idee war halt, er gibt allen Byteballs, die halt schon Bitcoins haben. Weil die, die Bitcoins haben, sind wahrscheinlich die, die sowieso entweder Kohle haben oder sich damit beschäftigen, sich auskennen und die wahrscheinlich auch ein bisschen festhalten und nicht gleich wieder ausgeben. Weil wenn die wieder auf den Markt landen, die Byteballs, dann sinkt der Preis auch wieder. Also er wollte die an Leute verteilen, die die wahrscheinlich erstmal aufheben. Und dieser Trick, dass halt jeden Monat welche rauskommen und dass man für den letzten Monat dann auch noch jetzt hier 20% von dem, was man schon hat, oben draufkriegt. Das sorgt natürlich dafür, dass die Leute jetzt Byteballs kaufen, weil sie dann zum Vollmond 20% oben drauf kriegen. So denken sie jedenfalls. Dass natürlich kurz nach dem Vollmond der Preis um diese 20% wieder zusammensacken wird, das berechnen viele nicht, weil wenn es ums Geld geht, dann sehen ja alle nur noch Dollarzeichen in den Augen.
Was sind denn Black Bites?
Black Bites ist wieder so ein Feature davon. Das sind so Bytes, da kannst du mir was überweisen, aber man kann es in einer, also eine Blockchain haben die ja nicht, sondern die haben ja diesen Direct Acyclic Graph. Aber das kann man sozusagen nicht so richtig sehen, wer davon wo zu welchen Adressen überweist. Man kann sehen, dass die jetzt ausgegeben sind, dass du es dann nicht nochmal machen kannst, aber man kann nicht sehen, wohin. Das ist halt so ein anonymes Feature, was diese Währung so mit drin hat. Das kann sein. Aber die Währung an sich ist nicht schlecht, dass der Typ so ein bisschen so ein Pyramidenspiel spielt, weil es halt jeden Vollmond gibt es was und dann 20% auf dem, was du beim letzten Mal bekommen hast, damit will er verhindern, dass man die wieder ausgibt, weil er will ja, dass die Leute das halten. Das 20% Zinsen ist das sozusagen monatlich, sorgt natürlich dafür, dass die Leute halten. Egal, wer Bitcoins hat, sollte sich das angucken, um da einmal abzukassieren. Wartet nicht, bis die letzte Ausschüttung gekommen ist, was so in neun Monaten circa sein wird, weil da werden alle verkaufen. Macht es ein bisschen vorher, ist mein Tipp an euch.
Okay, das war jetzt nochmal das Management Summary, wenn man jetzt irgendwie, was man jetzt machen muss, man muss sich was runterladen und dann was?
Na, man muss zu byteball.org gehen, man lädt dort die Wallet runter, man kann da im Chat mit so einem...
Welche, die Light-Wallet wurde gerade im Chat gefragt?
Die Light reicht, also man muss nicht da komplett sinken, das Light reicht. Wer was für diese Währung an sich tun will, der kann ja die mit dem Syncing machen und kann das dann volle Pulle da laufen lassen. Ich glaube, aber es gibt nur trotzdem eine Wallet, man kann den Modus sich dann aussuchen. Und wie gesagt, da mit dem Chatbot quatschen, dem beweisen, dass man Bitcoins hat und dann zum Vollmond gucken, wie man Kohle kriegt. Das dauert immer ein paar Stunden nach dem Vollmond, bis die ihre Datenbank da durchgerattert haben, aber man kriegt die. Ich hab das schon zweimal gemacht. Funktioniert. Die haben so ein Konzept von Oracles. Das ist irgendwie so, sagen wir mal, ich will jetzt meine Byteballs gegen Bitcoins tauschen, dann kann ich so eine Art Contract machen, dass ich, sagen wir mal, dir Timme, einen Gigabyte Byteballs rüber schicke, das Oracle da so gleich mit reinprogrammiere und sage, dass diese Überweisung soll nur stattfinden, wenn auf meiner Bitcoin-Adresse folgende Bitcoins angekommen sind. Und das Oracle gibt dann diese Transaktion erst frei, wenn wirklich auf meiner Bitcoin-Adresse deine Bitcoins angekommen sind. Das heißt, ich kann die Byteball-Transaction schon raushauen und irgendwann, wenn du deine Bitcoins überweißt, dann wird erst diese Transaktion ausgeführt und ich muss mich da nicht weiter kümmern, sondern das Oracle managt das. Und das sind schon coole Features. Und da ist alles in dieses Chat-System eingebaut. Also die haben da so gleich so ein Chat, in dem man auch gleich da handeln kann und so. Und das ist schon ganz cool. Was nicht so cool ist, ich glaube, das ganze Zeug ist in JavaScript gekodet. Es liegt ja erst um das Protokoll und um die Algorithmen und so weiter. Aber das ist gerade so der Geheimtipp, diese Währung. Es kann sein, dass sie dann, wenn die Ausschüttung vorbei ist, alle verkaufen, machen und zusammenbricht. Aber zurzeit sieht das noch ganz gut aus. Und man muss vielleicht kurz vorher aussteigen. Oder auch nicht und hofft, dass es danach fett abgeht. Kann man ja mal probieren. Wenn man keine einkauft, sondern beweist, dass man Bitcoins hat, dann kann man nichts verlieren. Man kann natürlich jetzt auch darauf hoffen, und das war die letzten Monate immer so, kurz vor dem Vollmund geht der Kurs von Byteball natürlich tierisch in die Höhe. Kurz danach geht er ein bisschen runter, aber nicht wirklich viel. Wahrscheinlich genau diese 20 Prozent. Und zum nächsten Vollmund geht es wieder tierisch in die Höhe. Also bisher ist es jedes Mal so, hat sich verdreifacht. Also diese Währung verdreifacht sich pro Monat.
Könnte man so sagen.
Und wie geht es damit weiter, wenn die letzte Ausschüttung passiert ist?
Na dann kannst du die ganze nochmal benutzen und von A nach B Byteballs schieben und so weiter.
Und dann gibt es aber auch nicht mehr Byteballs.
Er behält sich vor, dass er 1% behält für sich selbst. Das ist sozusagen das, was sein Verdienst sein soll. Das wird nur 99% ausgeschüttet. Oder es werden 98% ausgeschüttet, 1% behält er sich für sich selbst. Und 1% wird dafür benutzt, dass für jeden, der danach diese Wolle darunter lädt, der kriegt irgendwie eine Million Bytes oder so was. Also du kriegst gleich, damit du keine leere Wolle hast, kriegst du ein paar und dafür will er das letzte 1% benutzen. Das ist wohl aber erst dann, wenn es dann soweit ist. Also jetzt kriegt man noch keine 1 Million Bytes oder so. Aber ich bin mir da auch bei dieser Information nicht ganz so sicher, ob das so war. Aber so ungefähr. Und dann ist es auf jeden Fall vorbei. Und die haben zurzeit, ist ein Viertel der Bytes ausgeschüttet. Also 250 Milliarden Bytes, glaube ich. Und sie wollen eine Billion ausschütten. Jetzt in deutschen Zahlen, genau. Die haben das genannt, das ist ja bei uns eine Billion, richtig?
Das ist zwar einen Terra.
So, jetzt sagen wir nochmal, wie markiert man jetzt seine eigenen Bitcoins, dass sie da in dieser Verlosung teilnehmen?
Also du hast hier diese Wallet offen, da gibt's so ein Chatfenster da. Da gehst du rein und dann klickst du mal da oben irgendwie, da müsste so ein...
Bot-Store.
Ja, ich hab das hier auf meinem Laptop natürlich nicht, aus Sicherheitsgründen. Ich komm da kurz rum.
Können wir auch nachher machen, wenn es jetzt nicht verpasst. Es geht ja ums Erklären, nicht ums Machen.
Ist aber ganz easy. Es gibt zwei Methoden zu beweisen, dass man Bitcoins hat. Entweder man macht so eine Testüberweisung an deren Adresse, dann verdienen die natürlich immer so ein paar Cent, aber es ist wirklich eine kleine Summe, so ein halber Euro oder ein Euro. Oder man kann ja mit seinem Bitcoin Key auch eins dringend signieren. Man signiert halt einfach seine Byteball-Adresse und schickt dem diese Signatur. Dann weiß er, dass nur der Besitzer diese Adresse machen kann. Dann hast du auch bewiesen, dass das deine Bitcoins sind. So geht das.
Das geht mit der Bitcoin-Wallet, ja?
Dann mit der Signatur, ja. Oben im Menü gibt es das nur, glaube ich. Da gibt es so ein Create Signature oder so etwas. Und dann musst du da natürlich noch die richtige Absendenadresse ausmachen, weil du hast natürlich mehrere Adressen, wo deine Bitcoins verteilt sind, weil du kriegst ja auch so Change Coins und so weiter. Du musst dann die richtige ausfinden. Oder du musst vorher dein ganzes Geld auf eine Adresse nochmal an dich selbst überweisen, damit alles auf einer Adresse liegt und nicht so verteilt ist. Und damit signierst du dann irgendwie. Das ist noch ein bisschen fummelig, aber das ist alles irgendwie schon tausendfach erklärt irgendwo.
Gibt es dann auch Markets dafür?
Ja, es ist CryptoEx.pl. Funktioniert aber. Da tauscht man seine Byteballs gegen Bitcoins und das geht wohl. Die kannst du ja überall gegen Euros tauschen. Also der Kurs ist jetzt von den Dingern so bei 700. Das ist jetzt auch wie gesagt Sonntag ist ja der nächste Vollmond. Das ist schon Euro. Also ein Gigabyte.
Gib mir nochmal die Schokolade.
Circa 700 Euro. 811 jetzt. Das wird jetzt bis zum Vollmond, wird es jetzt noch hochsteigen wie Sau. Und am Montag wird es dann wieder runtergehen, wahrscheinlich auf keine Ahnung, 6-700 wieder. Und ja bis zum nächsten Monat ist dann drei Wochen lang Ruhe und eine Woche vom nächsten Vollmond geht es dann wieder ab.
Reich werden mit der Freak Show?
Ne, Dennis gibt ja nichts ab von seinem Reichtum.
Ich hab's dir angeboten, du wolltest nicht.
Dein Motorrad ist auch raus.
Ja, wenn ich irgendwas gelernt habe, Dennis, in meinem Leben ist. Deinem Rad sollte man oft folgen.
Ich hab's auch nur als Tipp bekommen. Und auch erst vor zwei Monaten und nicht leider schon im Dezember.
So, momentan wollen wir denn die Sendung beenden. Ich glaube, langsam müssen wir das beenden, oder? Ja, müssen wir. Auf jeden Fall müssen wir das.
Ich hab nix mehr. Doch, eins hab ich noch. 4D-Toys. Erinnert ihr euch an Mie Gakure? An was? Das 4D-Spiel, von dem ich mal sprach. Dieser Typ hat jetzt ein kleines, wie soll ich sagen, Demospielprojekt veröffentlicht, wo man unter iOS sich 4D-Dinge angucken kann. Im Wesentlichen ist es so ein Baukasten, so Bauklötze für 4D. Kann man mal drumrum spielen. Da kann man halt auch irgendwie so diese 120-Cell, der dann zu einem Dodecaheder wird, wenn man ihn irgendwie in 3D durchschneidet und so ein Zeug. Also das ist wieder dieser ganze Hirnfu in 4D. Das macht sehr viel Spaß.
Sich das...
Ich hätte nicht vorher die Schokolade noch. Macht voll süchtig, oder? Ich weiß, aber es ist jetzt auch ein bisschen schwierig, wenn die Fresse brennt, jetzt noch irgendwie ordentliche Sätze zu formulieren.
Ja, also in diesem Sinne. Wenn die Fresse brennt. Ja, du musst jetzt nichts mehr sagen. Die röchelt noch ein wenig herum.
Ich nehme noch einen Schluck Bier.
Ich finde, es stellt sich ganz schön an. Aber so ist das halt.
Überhaupt nicht. Wer ist denn derjenige, der hier so ein ganzes Stück gegessen hat? Das war ja wohl ich.
Du bist der Held, Roddy.
Ja, eben.
Aber du hechelst auch wirklich wie so ein Hund in der Wüste. So, was wollte ich noch sagen?
Also, 4D Toys heißt das.
Ich wollte hier noch vor allem dieses blöde Video ausschalten, dass es mir nicht dazwischen quatscht. Und dann kommen wir jetzt zum Ende der Sendung. Ist doch auch gut, oder? Letty, Dennis, Huckel, Roddy.
Scharfe Sendung gewesen.
Genau. Mit 6,4 Millionen Scroville schicken wir euch in die nächste Zeit. Mal schauen, wird ein bisschen schwierig jetzt im Juli, im August mit den Terminen. Aber wir sagen erstmal Tschüss und gucken mal, wie es ist, ne?